A record start broadcast
live.
Are We on the Air Gentlemen?
I'm trying to figure out how we're on
the map because I'm looking.
Here we go.
Pitches a what is this week?
Ten or some shit.
How many weeks are we doing this?
That's loving here.
I left.
It's so funny because after going
through all the old podcast,
every beginning of every single podcast,
I'm like,
you know that Tony into art bell,
please turn off your radio.
Right?
And A to.
There was people always call up that
feedback himself.
Well,
they're listening to themselves and then
they're at.
So it's like a nonsense conversation.
I don't even know what they want to hear
themselves on the radio,
so like just being in the moment,
record it with my cell phone,
turn up that radio.
Fortunately this is very different,
but yeah,
I guess we want to hear ourselves
broadcast.
So we got to show this weekend at the
Tempe Improv almost sold out,
so Saturday night sold out already
zoning.
A few tickets left for the late show.
Friday night is on its way and once we
get in and to trust.
So if you want to come in,
you want to see the show boss type is
always fun because our fears and Dead
Punch and they and they let us drink now
to dead punches a pool time that I
remember.
It took me a second dead stroke.
That's a hangar pool terminology.
Do you guys keep doing this to each
other now?
It just started by itself under the,
on both theaters.
You know,
a new computer.
I got it on both things.
I got it on this ustream window too.
And Brian is redoing my website and in
doing so,
just fucking master genius self.
He's put the uh,
the ustream actually on Joe Rogan.net.
So if you'd go to the webpage,
there's a,
there's a little corner link that says
live Webcam,
so you can see it right from there.
It's gonna get better.
It's going to get back.
And it's on itunes now too.
And you can find the official Joe Rogan
podcast on,
or is it just the Joe Rogan?
It's called the Joe Rogan podcast on
itunes.
So you can get that shit or if you have
zoom,
you could go to your website and
download the MP three.
Yeah.
If you're one of those soon dudes who
just hates apple so much.
You had to get one of the goofiest
fucking devices ever.
Unless it does anything better.
There's no need for another one soon.
The Microsoft version of the ipod and
the people that are that prefer it,
but it's how they're like super windows
heads.
People that just love it
because no denial.
Specialty old zoom.
Do you remember ever using that where
it's like a fake spin wheels that get
pushed it down and it clicked up and now
it was retarded.
So new one's not bad.
I guess they probably couldn't use the
technology.
Right?
Didn't you say that apple is assuming
that people for the technology that in
their iphone or android devices and
sprint devices,
they're all fucked right now because
they own or apple owns like 20 of the
patents that all these new cell phones
are using.
Why you have a phone like that?
That the android or the droid.
Wow.
It has pinch to zoom,
just like the iphone.
Well,
yeah,
they all,
apple owns all these patents.
So android might be hurting a android,
even palm.
It might be hurting because their new
phones are all really just pretty much
stealing of apples a shit.
Wow.
That would be nuts.
The only one that's not in trouble right
now.
I guess it's the new windows.
Seven phones.
So they don't use the pendants.
They haven't,
they,
they were really smart not to use any
patents.
They have their own shitload of patents.
So the problem is pinch to zoom.
There's no better way to do.
There really isn't.
No,
there has.
I'm sure there could be like a way that
you can make like circled as Uhm,
you know,
and it's squared.
It came circled.
C'Mon man.
You want,
you want to be able to pinch it.
Yeah.
But what if you wanted to zoom on in
part?
Just put a circle around
zoom now.
No,
no,
no.
I want to do this.
Yeah.
But if I took five years ago,
I was like,
no,
you can go like this.
I know that I can do that.
It's like when you have water in your
ear and the water gets out of here and
you're like,
oh,
now I can hear like you accepted the way
your ear was bursting when the water was
in there,
just like,
I'm okay with it.
I can deal with those people that still
aren't on the Internet.
Like I'll just pick two males pie.
There's a fucking awesome documentary on
PBS TV about this dude who lives in the
Arctic,
one of the last people that it's allowed
to live in the Arctic,
and he lives like way the fuck up in the
northeast part of Alaska.
Like there's no one within like hundreds
of miles.
Him,
he doesn't have a car.
He gets electricity from a generator and
he fucking shoots all his own meat,
kills all his own rabbits.
Kills on Caribou,
has to protect his cabin.
Little tiny ass cabinet,
like the size of a bedroom has to
protect his cabin from wolves.
Like it's fun going from a bear's rather
bears come to the cabin because he hangs
his meat outside because it's never
cold.
They don't have a refrigerator,
they don't have anything.
So he hangs his fucking meet outside and
bears occasionally will come into the
campus smelling.
So he's got this dog that he leaves out
that's supposed to protect and bark.
So then he comes out as to chase the
bear down on the fucking shotgun and
he's doing this in the nighttime.
It's night and he can't see and he's
chasing down this fucking bear and
shooting at it.
It is nuts.
Like this guy is living in the extreme.
I mean as as close.
I mean that's sort of civilized
civilization I guess.
Yeah.
He's got a television,
he's got a generator.
He can get electricity,
watches dvds that he gets shipped to
him.
He still has not seen a even an image of
the nine slash 11 towers falling.
Really know.
We heard about it on the radio.
Thought it was crazy.
But he lives up there.
Just him and his fucking wife.
Man.
It's a lot.
His wife,
she's not Russell Peters and Waterman's
right now.
Russell Peters has bill.
Russell Peters is the man.
He's one of the nicest guys ever.
Hi,
is this Russell who's and you have to
deal with it.
You can't just let it go.
It's there.
We're all thinking about it.
No,
he's faking that lives.
The other day Russell was hanging out
with somebody cool.
Like I forget the,
the old hip hop rap guy from the
eighties as it takes to Bismarck,
eeg know something like that.
I was hanging out with him the other day
and was Dj quick,
easy.
Roscoe.
I forget,
but I was like,
man,
that's so awesome.
Someone who knows what is the answer to
that question,
ladies and gentlemen,
you know that just about does it in a
song.
The maybe it wasn't rocket.
Now I'm screwed because I don't know.
That doesn't fucking savage.
It wasn't the right guy.
Now it doesn't matter who cared.
I were just talking about how rough you
remember.
Third base.
That'll wrap.
Third,
third base.
The white guy.
What happened to those guys?
I love them.
I do albums.
Two albums.
It was the DJ.
What the fuck is his name?
The white dude was good.
Prime Minister Pete.
Nice.
That was nice.
And was the other one.
And um,
I don't know what was his name?
Dj googler.
No,
I haven't had repeat.
Nice and
fuck.
Come on in folks.
Ron Bass,
rob base I think.
No,
no,
no.
Basis.
The other dude.
Yes.
This is
and now I'm just confused where one had
an MTV show.
Which one had the MTV show?
That's a good question.
Would that be nice?
Was that.
I know that was the next white rapper.
Rapper just wrote Dj boom,
boom.
You're just making shit up the DJ booth,
but I'll know the answer when I hear it.
Man.
Dj sniffle w who are the.
The third base is the band and there was
the white guy with glasses.
They were both white guy but the big
guy.
Right?
Prime Minister.
Pretty Nice.
And so and so.
What was it?
Anyway,
the other guy.
Who the fuck is it?
It's not Dj Eez rock you fuck.
No.
Richie rich.
No Mc search.
Isn't that amazing how your brain just
below up like immediately was it said,
why is it so hard?
I don't know.
Gum Inflammation.
It's like,
but then once that for.
It's weird when a memory gets awakened
when you didn't think the memory was in
your head at all and then someone brings
it up and also the rebirth,
the balloons comes back to life.
Like someone talks about some shit that
happened.
Like when you were a kid and you're
like,
oh yeah,
what the fuck,
I forgot about that.
All the sudden boom.
It was clear when that happens.
That opens up a lot of these little
memories that just because you
remembered that one thing being will
start remembering like,
oh,
and really used to listen to that guy at
the grocery store.
Bishop Desmond Tutu gets the gas face.
I don't know how much research was good
man,
like that guy's flow,
but it seemed like people would pick on
because he was white.
It was like.
And then he became like a producer
instead of a wrapper,
which I think was a huge mistake because
I think as a rapper he was really bad
ass.
It was fucking good.
Like I used to love his stuff,
but I felt like he was almost sort of
like doing it but sort of apologizing at
the same time.
She's a junior and he stopped doing it,
but the cashier will never stopped
rapping and that guy was fucking good.
The idea that he went on to produce some
records.
I'm sure he produced some good to stop
liking it.
Perform.
I can appreciate that.
But I think with him that guy was really
fucking good.
I really,
really used to enjoy as shit illegally
down both those albums to know I'm not
them for fuck,
I'm going to pay when we go to itunes
and give a fuck.
You gorillas album came out today.
What did you say you didn't like that?
I don't like the single first thing was
out there for all I know.
Is that one song they do do,
do,
do.
I know,
but I mean if I had to like identify
one.
Anyway,
so you searched.
Please come back.
That's what we're trying to say.
Come.
C'Mon man.
I ain't too late.
Just fucking dust off that hat and
fucking let's do this son to step up and
spit out.
I like.
I like rap music,
man.
I mean,
I joke about it in my app,
but I really do man.
It's fun.
I love that.
You know that they're talking shit.
I like listening to people talk.
She'll love it now.
So that's my landing.
No,
that's a great one too.
Not just a great writer,
but hip hop is dead.
That's my landing.
Music is.
I rotate between three songs.
Hip Hop is dead.
Tori Amos,
crucify.
And voodoo child.
What do you mean about learning music?
When I land,
as soon as I put my fucking land,
my touchdown will come into a new city
or even the question why the
stewardesses electric heavier earphones
on during landing first class,
but I knew it.
That's totally true.
I always say they never bothered me on
my class,
but on the back,
like tick it off.
Yeah,
they're Nazis in the bag.
You can't totally get away with it,
but you can kind of play dumb.
Like what?
Okay.
Take it off.
I mean,
I never don't take it off when they rate
off,
I take it off.
You have to tell me I'm not going to
take it off on my own.
The break and if you're sleeping they'll
never wake you up.
It will fake sleep.
I'll make sure that my seat is up for
that,
but you know,
I'm going to do this shit right here and
it should just let it go.
Please.
I'm nice.
It's no one's going to crash because my
fucking head turn it off because radio
waves.
No,
it's not a real wave.
It's electric.
They want you to turn off everything.
They want you to turn off game boys,
you know,
but it's like it's on.
It's nonsense.
The idea is some sort of electrical
interference,
but I think really the good idea too is
that it forces people to comply and
that's the same thing with putting the
seat up,
but you never really thinks it's
ridiculous.
And I used to think it was ridiculous to
force people to put their seat up.
But now I think it's important because
you've got to get them to fucking listen
to you.
Well important.
If they do get into a tough,
they don't want you to look lean.
But if you know,
if you can get hurt,
you're going to get hurt.
You know,
anything that's going to hurt you.
It's not gonna hurt you any less because
you're like this.
Then you are like this.
I mean,
you're going to get jacked,
I guess.
Maybe.
No,
I can't.
I can't see how even in the most furious
turbulence it would make a difference.
I think you're fucked either way.
If you're fucked,
you're fucked.
You're on a goddamn metal tube flying
through the air.
You know?
I think the good thing about it is that
they get you to comply.
And I think,
you know,
I don't want anybody to tell me what to
do and you don't want anybody to tell
you what to do,
but let's be honest,
we're not going to do anything fucking
crazy.
You know?
There's a lot of people out there that
need to be told what to do during the
landing.
I was like,
I'll just go to the bathroom on the
fucking fly all over the place.
Yeah.
I think people,
um,
there's a certain amount of people,
you know,
there's just too many of us.
We need very clearly established rules.
Even if they're ridiculous.
Even if it's just like,
it sounds like,
oh,
you're conservative,
but it's not just an expert retards,
you know,
I just know there's just so many fucking
dummies out there.
It's very important to have a certain
amount of order to the world,
you know,
because even though you don't want that
order,
you've worked really hard to put
yourself into a position where you don't
have to have that order.
You know?
I mean,
look at the life you chose,
you went from like a very obvious,
you know,
uh,
like regular normal person's life to
being this crazy fucking comedian where
you know,
you're making your living talking shit
on stage and you know,
you sleep till noon and it means that,
right?
That right there is most people would
never be able to figure out a way that's
just too tricky.
It's too fucked up.
You know,
like most dumb people would never be
able to figure out a way to slip through
some weird path to make a career doing,
watching your work.
Right now we're not talking about,
you know,
well,
nobody really wants to work unless you
love what you're doing and then it's not
working anymore.
And that's really the secret to life.
And then everybody loves something else,
man.
I mean there's a reason why there's
lawyers.
There's a reason why.
There's a lot of dudes who love being
fucking dentist now.
There's a lot of dudes and loved being
carpenters and everybody's got their own
thing.
Whatever the fuck it is.
If you want me to find it then it's not
really work.
You know?
And until then it's going to suck.
I still get surprised sometimes on the
road and be like,
Oh yeah,
okay.
Yeah,
I know.
It's because we do it so often for free,
you know,
especially in La,
how many I'm often do you do sets for
free?
Oh,
that's what I start.
Whenever people ask me like,
Hey,
do you want like a future for the third
show or something or whatever.
I'm always,
look,
I've said no before and then it's like,
yeah,
I do a guest spot now once I get there.
So it's like,
yeah.
And you hear the laughter,
you just want to go up.
There was,
it was we were in Australia,
the uh,
the,
the flight fucks you up man,
because it's like a 16 hour time zone
and it's like 19 ahead.
So it's like literally you're the next
day,
you don't know.
So I was like,
well really delusional.
I kind of,
I didn't know,
but as soon as I got to the club,
I saw the people who have interest
sparks it up,
you know,
it's crazy.
It's like Bam,
we're going to do a fucking trouble and
have some fun.
You know,
it's like you just fire up,
you just,
you just get one people,
man,
I wish people in their regular jobs
could feel what we feel when you're
killing,
you know,
occasionally sleep for a couple hours
afterwards to go on wired afterwards.
Especially when you got a new bit,
if you have a new button,
that new bid is killing that.
It just takes everything up to the next
level.
You know?
It's crazy.
Comedy is so much fucking fun.
He's seen alice in wonderland yet.
No,
I've heard very mixed reviews.
I am going to watch it.
A universal city walk on mushrooms.
When we got back from Tibet,
Arizona.
They're in three D imax.
Disregarding the law.
Have you not had a bad trip before?
No.
That's why he's going to be your bad
trip.
Here's what I thinking
about bad trips and I think for sure you
could definitely take too much of
anything and have a bad trip no matter
what state of mind is.
You know,
I've had that trips on pot.
I've never had bad trips and anything
else about pot,
but I've had bad trips.
Eating Pot.
I think it's a state of mind.
I think it's how you approach it.
I think it's where you're at when you
take it,
if you're in a good place.
Last time I did shrooms,
I start shooting and having diarrhea and
know that changes everything.
If you think you're dying,
that's causing mushrooms.
Somebody get into an accident across the
street from here.
That's all going back.
Are you doing that second dealer show
next time?
Sure.
If I can.
What is it takes a good show.
April 18th if you haven't seen it or
heard about it already.
Fear is doing.
If you live in la,
he's doing this psychedelic show and he
did it.
When was the last date was in February.
You got some clips on your website.
Look are going to make them better.
Well this,
so the idea of the show is most
comedians that we know at least most
funny ones because had a few psychedelic
experiences and a lot of them have
really funny stories to go with them and
so they're all talking about it.
Uh,
you know,
in front of a crowd.
It should be kind of cool.
There's just fun stories.
Anything interesting I've ever learned?
I've already told 100 fucking times.
Right?
I always get it.
Drug experience for you.
Oh God.
In Tempe this weekend.
That's the place to do it,
right?
God spirits in us and said,
you have some Guy Dylan Birdie told the
story.
You're always supposed to be incredible
synthetic spirit self.
My friend Matt was in New York and he
took it and he said he could hear people
talking in a building like straight way
over there.
I said a glass window,
and he goes,
I can hear them talking.
Meanwhile,
it's probably just like a cell phone
going off.
I mean,
I think.
I think there's,
there's,
there's ways we can perceive things
other than the standard way.
I'm not drunk.
I could hear things further away,
but like a center,
like at a bar weapon normally hear
nothing I can set on one person talking
know,
but people around me then I just see
them and I hear what they're saying.
That your liver,
your liver,
your liver does it.
Who knows when your liver is what makes
a week so fucked up when you eat it,
that's when it produces that shit.
It's called 11 hydroxy metabolite.
Apparently it's,
it's,
um,
it's present and smoking it.
When you smoke it,
it's present.
But it's not like a psychoactive levels.
But when you eat it,
it's processed by your body and it
produces this fucking insane chemical
that's like four times more psychoactive
than thc.
That's why when you eat pot sewing,
whoa.
Those brownies or cookies gave us and
Chicago Shit.
Even fucking Joey Diaz freaked out on
him.
Joey DSSD had a mild heart attack.
That was the first time.
We're all still high the next day.
And you wake up,
you're just kind of like shuffling your
feet.
Feel sort of weird.
Like you're still tired until it hits
you,
but you're not.
You're too high to think it out.
So you're like,
oh,
it was so hot.
I reevaluated my entire life.
I really did.
I made some life changing decisions that
night.
I was so fucking gone.
I literally,
I mean,
it was very,
very similar to taking mushrooms,
very similar,
just just as intense and just go into a
different place.
It was like,
wow,
this is strong.
And you know,
how I knew it was really,
really,
really strong is my laid in the bed and
I close my eyes.
And the hallucinations were insane.
It was all.
Yeah,
it was all these like these cartoon
characters fucking each other and and
becoming different things and fucking
each other and becoming different things
if fucking each other and becoming
different things.
It was insane and they were like,
the cartoon characters were like,
like a glowing,
almost like a neon.
The handling big glowing neon quality to
them.
Like they look like someone drew them,
but then there was like a glowing neon
like center to him.
It was fucking insane and went on for
like a half an hour.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is just from eating.
We'd,
I started ate mushrooms when I was
getting sick and stuff.
Then I resorted to bed and it was weird
because I went into like stages of like
first I was shaking real fast.
Date I went into like a sweaty and then
I got into like a thing that I felt like
I was going inside out or something.
It was like seven things,
but it was in a cycle,
like it kept on doing it.
Like I'm like,
all right,
next is coming to shake,
right?
Oh yeah.
Here comes a shake and stuff like that
and then I was like,
wait,
it's like seasons of the Earth Man.
Probably about 150 of those things and
yeah,
I mean that's how bad my last mushroom
tripwires.
And it was like,
it was sick mixed with thinking I was
some kind of season.
How much did take a,
about an eighth or half,
an eight,
75 percent of an eight or something like
that.
What does it need?
How many?
Uh,
people do have maybe
300,
33 point five,
four,
six or something,
right?
They say the real big doses,
like five,
five grams,
five grams.
See some,
you talked to some people and they're
just like,
no,
dude,
you got smoke seven joints to get the
most out of it.
Not really.
The way to really do it right is to not
smoke pot for a long time and then below
it the fuck out.
Just get high as a kite.
And then you have,
I haven't spoke for the last couple of
days and I was Paul.
Yeah.
But have you heard it?
But that's just a couple of days you
have you ever.
I talked to those guys like I don't trip
on one hit of aspects or fontane man.
You know there are definitely some
business man,
but don't you think that we all have
different chemical structures,
but it's like,
I bet you they didn't even try the one
dose thing.
They're just like,
no,
I like to kind of five pizzas.
Have you ever met a dude who just can't
drink?
I,
especially back in Boston,
I knew a lot of guys that they would
drink and then all of that,
I mean one drink and they were gone.
They just didn't exist.
When I went out with once one drink she
would go one drink in and then all of a
sudden she'd be throwing glasses and
shit and swearing at the same way that
somebody can completely handle.
It was nuts.
I mean it's one fucking drink and she
wouldn't be gone one drink.
It was like she was allergic to alcohol
or something.
There was something weird and she was
completely crazy.
There's one girl I knew that a Jewish
girl she's friends with on facebook,
it might be watching,
so I want say her name,
but I first time she smoked weed and
fucking religion,
man.
Huh?
Jewish.
I'd have to say that because I went to
you guys at least have a chance to find
out who.
All right.
So,
uh,
we at my house,
it's like I'm not good with weed.
Whatever.
She smoked,
one bong hit.
She stood up,
ran full speed into my bathroom,
hit the bathtub and just flew in the
bathtub and smashed her face in the
bathtub.
And I'm like,
but she wasn't.
She just was like,
oh my God.
That was like one hit.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
There's something weird in her.
Whatever DNA that snapped and medial,
you know,
we also don't realize how strong his
fucking weed is.
Right?
Because Mr.
Ohio Shit.
Really?
Yeah.
This was an Ohio.
Wow.
She's just a freak.
How bad was Ohio's?
We'd compared to California.
Oh,
it was Mexican brick.
We.
Is that where it's compressed where at
least you like this.
I don't have much.
We'd left,
but that one break you're just like
pulling out long time ago,
maybe it's gotten better and,
and kind
of in California,
I'm sure it's used again,
address broker back then.
So it was probably always existed.
It's,
you know,
the people that get arrested for drugs.
Why is it,
are we speeding?
You have a life sentence in your car
while you're doing something stupid,
like throw,
always talking on the phone without
using a headset or.
And they get pulled over for that and
also in the cops like why do I smell
weed?
You know?
And then he popped the trunk and he's
got a fucking giant brick of weed in the
back or you're parked on the side of the
road with your door open and a girl
sitting on your lap and you're like,
okay,
why do you have a gun in the backseat of
your car?
Why you so nervous?
Sweating?
What is it about these fucking trucks to
get busted?
And they have like 100 million dollars
for the weed,
like giant fucking semis.
Like how crazy is that?
Like a big gamble.
Let's take a chance.
US get through,
I've been a lost.
They must get through.
I bet 90 percent of them get through it.
They busted one of them in Arizona
because the guy had a ups drunk.
It was ups trucks stolen.
No,
it wasn't real.
It was a forge,
a fake ups truck.
They made a ups truck with fake numbers.
I just took the numbers from one of the
other ups trucks.
They wrote it down.
They recreated a fucking nice truck.
Yeah,
brilliant.
And why are they going to do it?
But because the cops ran the fucking
number that was on it,
they were speeding or doing something.
The cops ran the number that was on it
and it turns out it was,
it was the wrong truck.
It was so like,
no,
we're in Michigan match.
It didn't match for whatever reason.
So they decided to pull them up.
I said,
pull this guy over.
He's got a giant fucking truckload a
week.
I mean they just decided to pretend that
they're delivering for ups.
They're pretty good.
Nobody would check it.
They probably got away with it a fuck
load of times,
you know.
And then one guy just got a little care
list and started driving fast and you
got Boston.
They always get complacent.
We get away with it,
totally normal.
And you feel like I'm not going to get
caught.
You know?
I mean that's what.
And that becomes part of the thrill of
it too.
I think for people.
There's a lot of people that are
addicted to crime and they think that
crime like selling weed or do anything
illegal where you,
you know,
you don't really even pay taxes on it.
Think there's a fucking a wild outlawed
real to that shit.
You know,
some people love living like that.
But those mother fuckers,
you can't be around them.
They're going to blow up like that shit
is not going to last like you're,
you're not,
you're not playing by society's rules
when you're running around selling
drugs.
I liked to get drugs and I think it's
awesome that you're doing that,
but I'll be around you because if you're
the guy who's making his life of
selling,
you know,
if you're making your life off selling
cocaine,
like you might be fucking crazy.
You know,
you might just be a reckless wild
motherfucker.
That's a dangerous thing.
I mean,
how many people get rich and retire off
of cocaine?
I don't know.
Any.
And then what is a few of the year
buddy?
Cocaine cowboys.
Really?
She's,
she's still alive.
Cocaine cowboys too.
She got out and like retired now.
They shipped her to Bogota.
She killed her.
200 people.
Oh really?
Yeah.
She made hundreds of millions of
dollars.
She was killed.
Two people overdose are directly
responsible for like 200 people dying
off her coke.
Right.
What are you doing?
Somebody asked what I was drinking.
I was putting it up to them like
Weirdos.
It's good.
He's like,
I'm here on this chart.
I thought it wasn't fair.
That would be weird.
Really,
really weird.
Anyway,
this is still alive.
They took pictures of her in Bogota,
Colombia,
so she got out of jail.
They won't be deported there and now
she's running around Columbia.
Man,
he's rich as fuck.
She's like incredibly,
incredibly rich and ruthless.
The cocaine cowboys is fucking
incredible.
I thought,
oh my God,
you have to watch it.
It's one of the greatest documentaries
ever,
and then cocaine cowboys too is even
better.
Cocaine cowboys tube is just fucking
nuts,
man.
Mean it tells you.
It just shows you how nutty Miami was in
the 19 eighties when cocaine was coming
through there.
I mean,
it just changed the fucking face of the
city.
That city was built on cocaine.
The cops,
there were so many corrupt cops that one
year,
the entire graduating group in the
police academy,
the entire graduating group,
all of them either wound up dead or
locked up in jail.
Really?
Yup.
All of them.
I hate Miami so much.
Oh my God.
It's so crazy and that's why it's the
coke.
It's a cocaine flavors city.
There's a lot of cool people in Miami,
man.
I had a show recently.
I did the Lincoln theater was fucking
awesome,
man.
It was really awesome.
Everybody was super cool to show was
nice,
but fuck man.
That,
that Improv.
Perhaps the worst improv comedy club
I've ever been to ever.
That Miami Improv made me stop going to
Miami.
It was so bad.
They would just yell out shit.
Nobody gave a fuck,
it was just like tables,
just screaming at the top and you shut
up.
What giant room full of coke heads.
I mean just a room full of coke heads.
We're not even lying about this.
Like if,
if we had 200 people in the crowd,
how many people do you think were coke
heads?
How many?
200.
I'd say 80 to 80.
We're on coke.
80.
Iranco 40 doesn't have any on them.
That's not bullshit.
And the 40 that didn't have it on,
they might get shitty because they're
coming down.
I mean really it was fucking.
That place was crazy.
And Cuban Cuban cooked up in that place
is one of the one place is.
I've never heard headliner get more
sabotage when they decided to put Kevin
Mania after Joey Diaz.
You're talking Cuban and cokehead.
That's what I mean.
The audience is Cuban,
right?
The audience does.
Does,
you know coke and Shelly?
It has like an hour of material.
He could go on and on way.
He says it's so funny you say that
sounds funny.
I think it say somebody just die
laughing.
You're like,
oh,
you know about this.
He says,
Shit that I don't even know.
I've never done coke,
but it's funny just because there are
times a lady on a Thursday,
you know?
I don't know if he,
if he does that to a room full of coke
heads.
Oh my God.
Joe Used to destroy them.
He was still level that motherfucker.
He was on stage once and he was spitting
and sweat was flying off him and he was
telling jokes about being in one window.
They're both on coke,
humane is cat and he's in one window and
the cats and the other one and they
fucking looking out for police.
I don't think I've ever left any harder.
I don't think I've ever left any higher.
And Joey,
so Julie's leveling these audiences with
this kind of material.
And Kevin Meeney went up after him and
Kevin me this before Kevin Meehan count
came out of the closet for Ketamine.
He was doing like he used to do.
We are the world.
The tribute thing,
like a whole song that was closing bit,
but this was like decades after that.
We are the word,
nobody remembered that anymore and these
20 year old people in the audience had
no idea what the fuck he was talking
about and this is after Joe Papp and
yeah,
they're in their animals and this is
after Joe.
He goes up and she always just leveling
the place.
I mean it was,
it hurts you to watch it hurt you to
watch.
That's one of the worst.
Like scheduling of comics ever.
They do that all the time.
Like especially like the punisher.
No,
they did to people like not smart comic
wants too much money.
Sometimes they'll do that,
you know,
some,
some people don't think of guys that
good,
like some bones are really fucking
stupid.
He's just responding.
Well,
what I heard was the one who I heard got
fuck with the most was Mitch Hedberg.
Mitch Hedberg got fucked with a bunch of
times where they would put on like these
singing black guys before him,
you know,
and these guys would destroy with like
really dumb hack shit.
And then Mitch Hedberg regard whether
it's really weird,
unique act,
you know,
that like on paper isn't even funny,
it's like,
it's got some great stuff,
like an interesting way of delivering,
but it was,
it's very much you have to set it up
correctly.
You can't have some guy going up singing
and dancing and having a full audience
clap along.
And then Hedberg who just basically
stands there and you know,
doubletree hotel,
you know,
if he's got like all these weird jokes
that are like,
they're just so,
you know,
so uniquely him.
But you got to set it up,
right.
You know,
and that's,
that's part of comedy.
Let people go there.
God can follow that guy.
It doesn't mean that,
that guy's not good.
It means that they're actually aren't
compatible if people don't have a harder
time following the other people.
But those people would have a harder
time following people that I don't know.
Sometimes titles.
There's a lot of guys like really super
cerebral and really wordy and doesn't
swear and Israeli,
you know.
Then you go up and you want to talk
about get your Dick sucked.
You know,
people are like,
Whoa,
fuck earns for some reason and we're
killing it.
I would always do well when other people
are killing that I have trouble and it's
like I don't.
Yeah,
I just styles.
Yeah.
Joey used to have his,
his jenks used to be a Jamal,
you remember?
Oh,
he was amazing.
Incredible timing agents.
Most such a proud man.
He just,
his timing was just so perfect.
You hear the same jokes 10 times in a
row and he's still would laugh and for
whatever reason I think that just got
inside Joey's head because Joey wasn't
that kind of a guy who wasn't a
technician,
like a j.
Jamal just had that perfect timing.
It just,
the way he would do it,
like you would just be recovered from
the last job and then the next one would
hit you.
But we,
he do the right time.
Like why we're still appreciating that
show and then other one hits you and he
would hit you with these waves and jelly
was just a,
you know,
sort of like stream of consciousness guy
which just go up.
We had a couple ideas of some jokes he
would talk about,
but he want to just fuck around.
They wanted to like,
find,
find the material onstage.
I think it bothered him with this guy
was like so,
uh,
so rigid and that used to bother me a
lot too.
And I had a really strong impact,
was really strong and well done.
It would make me insecure.
I would say,
what is mine that good and I'm not doing
what he's doing.
Have trouble falling asleep if somebody
does real real well with crowd work.
But it's like,
because then that's my
pull up move and gives some power.
But then it's like,
well he just did it already.
He did it better than you.
It's not my one cheat move his fucking
taken away
from it.
Yeah.
The crowd was a good move.
If you get,
if you've got a position to go to it.
I don't want to say the job,
but you know,
there's one that you do where,
you know,
you talked to a check in the audience
and it,
you know,
you,
I always wait for it.
Like when you started talking about that
and then I go here comes like if you're
in a tricky situation,
he bust that one out.
That's just a crack in the face,
you know,
but those are nice to me.
It's really no different than any other
kind of job that you're gonna just mean
you're recreating the moment,
you know,
you're,
you're saying it all like you're
thinking it right there and then.
But a lot of it is shit.
You said many,
many times before,
you just got to keep it as organic as
possible.
The electrode,
because it sets my mouth to be like this
is a real clock on.
That's smart.
Yeah.
Why jokes on went to the store.
It sounds gross.
Yeah,
it does.
When is it ever sound grosser than when
you're in a tiny little audience?
When a audience,
like three people,
you see all the problems with your
material,
like tiny audiences are really good to
do because when you perform in front of
like three people,
it's so uncomfortable that you're making
this person talk to you.
The illusion of a crowd is just gone.
It's just like,
what are we doing?
I prefer for two ones,
two people at danger fields in New York
City,
and it was one of the.
It's the weirdest feeling.
It makes you snip out the fat and your
jokes.
It makes you get to the point quicker.
You respect their attention span more
because it's more ridiculous for you to
require them to listen to you,
but you also can't pretend like you're
doing a pause.
That might be setting their theatrical.
Even a good word.
Yeah.
I can't even do it now.
It's not even a bad thing.
Just seems really fucking weird.
Fucking fake.
You find out what the fake shit is.
You can do a pause if you're really
thinking that way.
You know if you're like,
you know,
there's a moment you app.
We're like,
what?
What the fuck?
What is really,
what is that?
There is a real moment.
There's a real opportunity for a moment
there,
but it has to be real.
I think very often we write stuff and we
write it and we say it in a way we just
know it's going to kill you know,
and it's not necessarily the way you'd
say it in front of a small group of
people.
It's good to clean your act up with that
shit.
It's good to do shows where people
aren't impressed too.
Like that's why it's good to do those
improv shows like those Wednesday night
shows because they don't know.
You Ain't gonna be there.
They're not your fans.
They don't come to see you.
They come to see any kind of comedy and
just saw 10 guys that had been on
television.
The guy from comedy jokes just wrote me
yesterday and he was like,
Hey,
uh,
already we'd love to have you come back.
And they did it before and I like,
oh cool.
I didn't want them that.
The guy who booked it left.
Um,
so I've been looking at to get in
contact with you.
And he was like,
yeah,
anytime you want next week,
the week after the week after that.
And I was like,
how about the week after that?
This is Ari?
And he goes,
oh no,
how about April?
And I'm like,
you thought it was area spirits?
Then he was like,
yeah,
I did.
I think an auto completed on it or
whatever.
And I was like,
it's fine man.
That habits.
No,
the webcams on guys.
Tell me a little story.
We're not stare at people that my
manager called,
you know the guy that no one else knows
everything.
I thought that was a good story man.
I'm fucking.
He wanted to go to comedy Jews comedy
juices.
Was it all related man coming juices.
The local show on Wednesday nights at
the Improv.
Really good show.
And there's always like,
you know,
famous Louis Ck and stop mark Merrill
stopped by.
All these good guys stopped by.
So it's a good place to perform,
but it's good to do like little time
shitholes too,
right?
It's good to do like bars and dives and
you know,
what's great is that little room next to
the Improv.
You know there's the big improv because
it's that little tiny ass during the
winter coat show.
What?
Show show?
No,
no,
no.
I mean in Tempe.
Oh yeah,
no,
that one.
No,
never going to watch.
I just watched todd glass goes and just
does that room.
No,
so fucking sweet roadmap.
You know what I mean?
It's one of the suites rooms in the
country and is connected to one of the
biggest firms in the country in all
things.
It's like a comedy complex.
It's amazing.
The Tempe has so much comedy,
you know?
It's.
It's also the biggest virgin with it
said Chicago might be bigger.
Now listen to me in west palm is bigger
than all other.
They redid it is west palm is shoes.
It's like 700 people.
It's fucking insane.
You walk in and you're like,
what?
Like it's so big.
What is San Jose have?
Let's see,
like $500 for 5,700
people,
something like that.
At least six,
but apparently it's hard to fucking
fail.
That's hard to go to.
Bruce,
bruce and good real quizzes every other
week.
CFA on his twitter the other day he had
with some guy who was making fun of them
or something.
That type portfolio would have happened.
It's just.
It's very crazy.
I'll.
This guy got to him and he just started
shooting.
I own you.
I bet you spend more time on me than any
other comedians.
He actually like I own you and the
punisher publicly show somebody else
online.
You're not showing them up.
You're just.
It's just,
you're both of you guys just back
because I can't ever hear a response.
I did that before.
You feel like an idiot,
you know,
afterwards,
why did I waste my time doing this?
But there's sometimes where you read
something,
someone will say something Douchey and
you're like,
I can just crush this idiot right now.
What?
I'm going to cry.
And then I was like,
what am I doing here?
Why am I entering in?
Like people are just drawing into some
silly fight.
Twitter.
Talk about that.
And they said to Marin and they said,
oh,
it's like the Special Olympics.
Even if you win,
just so retarded.
Yeah.
That's like a dessert,
like a picture of that.
It'd be really funny.
Inspirational pictures.
Would it be really funny?
It's,
you don't.
Somebody have like this online war or
somebody I just haven't gone back and
forth and get became.
So daisy,
you go to fight them.
It's like a 44 year old.
Well,
the thought is your kid.
It was
25 kid from a call from Ohio.
We brought them to the show.
Turned out to be just a kid fucking
around.
He was a nice guy.
I met him.
I talked to him on that.
Jimmy can't tell tone to he and I had a
space battle and it was a really
ridiculous.
And um,
uh,
it got put on some websites and then
when I went and I,
like,
he and I went back and forth on it and
even in the emails he said like,
you know,
alright,
you win.
And he said,
if I ever meet you I would be to shake
your hand.
I said,
I'll check your attitude so I'll just
fun.
Right?
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
well,
it's nice talking to you.
I give the end.
Did like,
okay,
you know,
I mean it was really weird.
It was like,
you know,
sometimes you talk shit to people,
you don't really mean what you're
saying,
but it's like you're,
you've ventured into like a little
contest.
So you want to talk stupid.
Do you want to say some dumb shit while
I'm up?
The of the people that think just
insulting your mother will do the trick.
Oh,
come on,
I fucked your mom three times.
Boom.
Teams.
But for comics and for us,
that's a fun exercise.
Sometimes that's the problem.
It's like when people know that you do
like to get mad at you,
like,
who wouldn't asshole?
He's calling this guy loser.
Maybe you're a fucking loser.
You think you're fucking bad ass because
you're on TV.
But no,
I'm just practicing dealing with Douche
bags.
It's like they're like online hecklers.
It's like the same thing as a heckler in
an audience.
It's really the same thing and just
breaking them down for a comic.
That's fun.
Sometimes I wish he would throw it
online.
I don't do it online anymore.
I used to.
It's just so stupid.
It's like you're,
you're,
you're deciding to get upset and to
enter into this little,
this little competition with someone who
you don't know who chooses to interact
with you.
That's what,
that's the way they choose to interact
with you.
They choose to attack you and you're
just going to submit to that and start
going back and forth,
and that's ridiculous that they win
right away.
You're,
that's just part of being in the public
eye.
Part of being an entertainer.
You're going to get people that want to
hate you.
That's normal.
As soon as you get back involved,
you're like,
maybe I'll show them up.
You won't.
No matter what energy,
that's what it is.
It's a waste of energy.
Unless you can do it and you're just
having fun and it's good natured and you
know,
and you do it just for shits and
giggles.
As long as it's good nature,
but if you're really getting upset and
you're really trying to hurt their
feelings,
so my role is to is if you will just
want to show them the error of their
ways.
You never will.
They'll never see it.
Felt.
Think that they showed you up some rare
for like a reflective moment,
like you know what man you might be able
to with with no aggression.
Like you might be able to show someone
like just,
you know,
a very calm way.
It's very hard.
It's very hard for them to accept it,
but the occasional person will accept
the occasional person who's just
confused.
A lot of people mad.
The reason why they lash out is because
really they just want someone to love
them.
There's no one loves them.
You know?
And this is all a lot of fucking humans
out there,
man.
There's a lot of people that they live
these terrible fucking lives.
I think.
I don't know who it was.
I think it was some fucking famous guy,
Ralph Emerson.
I don't remember who it was her.
This is this quote.
Oh fuck,
goddammit.
Hi Taylor.
Got To A.
Somebody yelled at him in the
supermarket parking lot because we're
going in the wrong way and somebody is,
you know,
I got into an accident once that way and
he said,
he goes,
yeah,
I bet you got to an accident.
Someone's going the right way.
What does that mean?
Anything quote?
What was it was November.
I don't remember too much weed.
Alright.
Tempe,
Arizona.
This clicker.
And there's been a lot of good questions
or the questions.
Give us one.
Brian sent it out loud.
Start talking about comedy.
I don't know.
Uh,
how,
what are the other questions in the
question for them?
Listen,
you don't have to watch it float if
you're not enjoying it.
You just fucking gone.
I give up on the Oscars when,
uh,
in the bedroom last to that fucking
terrible mine or whatever.
The split personality going on.
I was just like,
oh,
more than Avatar.
And that just hurts my soul because I
know that you like the hurt locker,
but I just,
it hurts me to why?
Because especially when the boring ass
fucking movie and I just can't
understand why everyone thinks it's like
the next awesome thing if the movie they
like or don't like when some fucking
award one.
Because then there's a movie like Avatar
that's just something brand new.
Like I've never seen this before.
I've never experienced anything like
this before.
Did you get an appetite depression when
you found out it wasn't real?
There's a whole thing with that.
People miss that because it's like a
form of depression,
you know?
I've only seen it once,
minister,
you saw it three times.
I've seen it one,
so I'm just saying I thought together.
It's fun,
man.
It was a fun movie.
It was like a God damn comic book or
going to the common man.
It's just like the Pocahontas so shut
up,
shut the fuck up.
I don't care.
I like stories that wrap up nice and
neat.
Whatever.
People say that shit shorty.
Shorter Shit.
He was like,
no,
you're right.
When they pointed out that that was a
little out of a little bit,
but whatever.
It's fun.
No good reason I care is because it
seems like.
Okay,
you saw the same movie.
I saw.
You think that was enough to be amazing.
That window.
That's weird.
I think I'm on a brave,
like a wave length.
What people's intelligence and how
they're thinking and that just blows it
out of the water.
Like there was a million movies
better than hurt locker.
I think I liked the hurt locker math.
I was pretty good.
That's going to be the year.
You know what I didn't like.
No,
no.
I thought it was a unique movie.
I thought it was.
I don't know.
I think probably because of the fact
that we're in this middle is unpopular
war and it was very,
it was actually art at a point.
I think so pointless will warn you know,
but um,
you know,
a solution.
That's one of the reasons why you got
extra special treatment.
I mean,
I think if this was done and who knows,
it could be done during the year where
there's no water will reflect on how we
don't have more movies all the time,
but I thought it was pretty good.
Man.
I really liked it.
I've watched it.
Granted while being held captive on a
plane,
you,
I couldn't go anywhere else in my seat.
I couldn't go anywhere.
And so I enjoyed it.
I was actually looking forward to it
because I've heard a lot of people said
good things about it.
I thought it was pretty good.
It was interesting.
It wasn't.
I didn't know too much about it,
so that was good.
I didn't know any spoilers.
It captivated me the whole way.
That movie took place four years ago.
Right.
That scene of that movie.
But here at the beginning,
I think he's playing xbox 30,
60 fucking funny.
I read that last night.
Fucking cat.
My first commercial knocked out.
My course was thorough the my first
commercial.
Well that's interesting man.
So did you read about this online or did
you figure it out yourself?
Easter egg?
No,
the Xbox PC.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm a movie nerd like that.
I read it.
Or You could say the date of the movie,
like I guess so yeah.
Tip.
It was uncontacted or something like
that.
Yes,
it was for you thought it was great to
too.
So you guys didn't sit there and go,
wow.
I just watched one really slow mission.
There was a little more crazy actually.
Yeah.
But I never knew what the fuck was
happening.
It wouldn't be exciting and you shot two
times,
but the first time you did not fucking
know that I was not going to blow up.
Yeah,
and it was very scary.
There was a part in the beginning of the
movie when that guy blows up spoiled.
There's a lot of shit that happened.
See,
I never felt the tension.
Tension,
tension though.
It was an excellent.
We're getting Jack what you're saying.
There were a couple of times we'd feel
authentic but.
But a lot of it was slow.
It was slow.
I understand that.
The attention perks I guess with dental
work and they failed.
Well,
I wasn't stones.
They succeeded.
They don't have to be.
I wasn't.
I was totally sober.
I
was in bed going.
I mean I was at the movie theater,
a movie theater and I didn't see
anything.
Maybe that's the problem,
man.
You in the ship copy.
It was at Blue Ray pop.
Rick.
I mean it was at the Imax theater and
three days to fuck Brian.
What are the Ria?
Busted down your doors.
Took you out of here.
You don't have anything illegal on,
you know,
just everything about that man.
Do you think we're getting really close
to the point where you can just download
shit and put it directly on your TV and
super high quality in real time?
We were there,
but I mean like I heard about it.
People do really easily with Mac Minis
and stuff like that and make money with
movies.
Well,
people are still going to the movies,
right?
Sure.
I don't care.
Yeah,
it'd be nice if everyone else does
except me.
People still down there.
Maybe.
Was there any copies of Avatar online
anywhere?
Yeah,
but a lot of people still went to see
that.
That's the whole point is that you will
download like stupid comedies and you're
just like,
I'm not paying to see that.
I'll fucking downloads with Sony.
Has a new TV coming out that's a three d
TV right out of a mall.
It comes out this summer.
Right?
It's fucking crazy.
You put goggles on.
They have a battery,
you press a button and these guys are
playing soccer and the ball is just
flying.
It models the TV,
the TV's wacky.
My other goggles on.
You look at it like,
oh,
so you look at right now it's a capable
of Samsung.
You Hook up a computer to it and it
renders anything in three d into three d
just like that.
So when Avatar comes out on three d,
You can do that until it gets to.
But so I'm not going to buy those
goggles and programming is like for us,
the office.
Is that coming through?
That's a good question.
I don't know how the crazy.
I don't think the three d is going to
catch on program,
but how many people you might think it's
cool,
but you know how many people are like,
you know what,
I'm going to buy a whole new tv just so
I could have this three d.
especially after they've made us all
bond new ones.
Work.
HDTV took a long blue rays.
Barely still kept holding on.
That's true.
That's true because regular TV still
looks pretty fucking bad ass and people
go,
how much better is it?
Really Bucks instead of 20 bucks.
No,
in this economy you pay 20 bucks and you
get the right middle one could give a
shit and honestly three d to me man,
like even when I go to the imax movie
theaters,
I'm still kinda like,
you know what?
I don't know if I like this yet,
you know,
like it's Kinda cool,
but you need to just go ahead and suck
some caulk.
Just go run.
In San Francisco it's getting better and
better on to wherever the hardest cock
you thinks gonna be awaiting.
It's getting better and better and
better,
but you still feel like they're looking
through something.
Like it still hasn't gotten to the point
where I'm like,
I completely disagree.
I go to that movie theater and it
doesn't feel perfect,
but I've put those glasses on and I
watched those dudes in Avatar floating
inside that room.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is awesome.
That movie is an event.
It's not just
a movie.
It's not just you go and watch a bunch
of shit happen.
The thing that's great about Avatar,
it's like a Goddamn comic book,
right?
It's like a ride,
like a super ride at universal city walk
and it's one of the things I said about
it,
like the acting is Kinda clunky.
Alright,
so going weaver sounds like she's
nailing it in a bunch of times.
Yeah.
She gave you the fuck up.
Like,
come on guys.
Are we serious here?
Where's my cigarette?
It's like,
whoa.
It seemed like the kind of acting that
you see in those rides at universal city
walk like right before you go on the
ride.
They make you watch them back to the
future clip where they explained what
happened.
We were in a bad situation guys.
We've got to get through the tone for
the nuclear bomb.
Looks like just don't much time please
in an orderly fashion.
Hurry up and get into your chair.
My popcorn wasn't laying when,
when they said when all the other armies
came out to fight them and was like,
oh,
we got all the other risk about like
what we were there the whole time.
I've heard about them.
They're right over there.
So why don't you just get them earlier?
Yeah.
Like what are you guys doing in order
for it to really work?
They all,
these places that bought their hd
cameras now have to buy three d cameras
and like all these shows have to be
filmed a different way and that's going
to happen,
Brian,
because he used to have to do black and
white.
That's what they did.
They did black and white with black
color who hasn't called hd.
They're kind of go,
why?
Why wouldn't ended up happened already?
Because the media has been huge.
The next technology isn't that
interesting.
During the black and white early color
years of television,
when you first saw the red,
you would probably.
This is a break year to someone who saw
jaws.
Three d theater.
The shark comes at you like,
yeah,
it's so dumb.
Back then you also thought video games
were like this that were like amazing.
That's why things improve and technology
advances and that's why three days
finally come into its own.
I just think that three d would have
been popular.
It was good.
There's no way you got greedy.
I think it's the future for sure.
Movies away.
Way more excited when they're in a
greedy way.
More interesting.
It's more layered.
It's like shit.
I heard the video.
The
visuals are incredibly wrong.
Did you read the article on in Gadget?
No,
this guy told me puts a detailed review
of the white sox and red.
It makes so much sense.
Like,
like the director use layers in the
movie in certain ways to give an effect
of depth and then the three d comes in
there and changes what he was doing and
it's supposedly just does not work.
So it would be cool if you saw it today.
Hey.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what you said.
It wasn't filmed for three d and that's
what I'm saying.
All of these avatar was avatar was
burden.
Does Not know his films being filmed for
three days.
No,
no,
no.
Two.
He did not film it for Three d movie.
That's what I'm trying to stay.
Avatar was filmed in the regard that
they filmed it as a two d movie and made
did it for three.
Right.
Okay.
Oh,
I don't know.
I'd have to see it.
That's what I'm saying.
All these shit would have to be filmed
in three d and it's going to take a lot
of people to go,
really?
We want to spend his whole movie being a
three d movie,
like jaws,
three d,
they had to go back with your crazy,
listen to me dummy.
They're gonna do it for every single
gigantic explosive and it wouldn't make
sense to make them much more so I
wouldn't make sense for every monster
movie in Three d,
so they will make way more than two days
and three days.
Second sales.
Oh No.
Because I do both doing a ton more,
but you do both at the same time because
just theater just hypes up the sales of
the two.
They had to rerelease jobs three and non
three d because it didn't do so fucking
terrible fucking thing came.
It was like there's only like one effect
to.
It was like,
it was so dumb.
I was like,
one effect the shark coming at you.
It was like such a stupid ass moving.
They're like,
we're not in the ocean.
We got it stopped,
but that's my bet.
You're what?
I think three days going to be fail.
What do you think's going to skip
through them?
What's next?
Like more better than that kind of
rejection.
Hologram in your house type shit,
dude.
I think that's coming to.
I think you're right,
but I think until that does come,
this is pretty fucking so it's going to
come more where a wall like paper,
LCD technology where this whole wall is
going to be like computer,
large size.
This screen.
I don't think it'll ever get to a point
where everything is controlled by your
voice or you think that that's just
really.
But what about if you don't want to
talk,
what if it's late at night?
Because my password,
it's like on password xxx.
No,
but yet we'd have another interface or
keyboard or something.
Keep going.
Yeah.
You just go up to the keyboard.
Will keep be here or do you think
divorce recognition will get so good
that be irrelevant?
I think eventually it will get so good
at.
Do you use voice technology at all?
Do you ever use it?
I used it briefly on my android and it
was amazing.
It was way better than I've ever used
it.
It was personal.
I keep hearing about that because it's,
it's okay
with some things.
SoK with blackberry,
blackberry,
you could say like call Brian and it'll
will call you.
You know,
it's pretty good about that.
Which number?
Cell calling?
Yeah,
my car.
It works.
Well,
that's bad.
In my car I have the Ford.
Yeah.
And it's like a call Joe.
Well,
but number two,
but I think that's also the noise of the
road.
That's why I like a instead of the,
you know that when you do it in a car,
it's a speakerphone.
It's like talking to Chris.
So what I always do is I would do it
straight from the phone.
So you're talking right into that little
tiny Mc.
It's pretty direct.
Seems pretty accurate enough.
You know,
it beats having to press buttons.
I don't want to press buttons when I'm
driving.
It's all come through the Bluetooth so
them.
Because that's one of the coolest ever.
You know that you could have a,
you could drive in your car and talked
to people on the phone with both hands
on the steering wheel nuts.
Just nuts.
Did you hear about this company
overseas?
Uh,
is released in the first jet pack that
you can buy.
There's going to be about 500 of them
being made for that 70,000
each.
So I don't have to go above 30 feet.
I'll go to $200.
Class 30 minutes,
I believe God and time,
30 minutes.
You'd be bored.
Already.
Fly.
Fuck that.
Toyota can't even get their jet pack.
And you only go five feet off the
ground.
Just keep fucking with whatever freaks
out and goes 500 feet in the ground and
you're stuck.
You'd have to have some sort of a
parachute,
right?
Yeah.
Be able to cut the jet pack off to the
extra weight.
Imagine we dropped down so much fucking
head.
You wouldn't mind.
You mother fucker planned out and just
say how many toilets were recalled in
Japan last night in San Diego?
Did you hear about it?
And the guy couldn't stop and the police
got to the side of it was like,
he just gets peers,
like hit the power button up and the guy
was kept on hitting the power button
when working was standing on the break.
He said just like full blast.
She'd go in and do and then he put his.
I don't understand it,
but I think it has something to do where
it's just won't let you do anything.
Uh,
and then the cop had to get in front of
them and I guess in like the,
so,
you know,
kind of break his car.
Oh my God.
I'm guessing that's standard clutch,
you know,
you gotta put it in yourself,
go down that way.
We have a standard,
even a manual transmission,
you can always put it into zero and into
neutral.
But the emergency brake doesn't work.
Yeah.
I don't care how it.
Maybe maybe the computer wouldn't let
the transmission to switch gears and no
emergency brake,
mercy break doesn't.
This was on a broker,
you know,
so you know,
you would have definitely put that on.
And not to even try.
But I mean,
he say he was standing on his break to
George Lucas says that he's found things
that are wrong with the Prius and he
says it's a software issue that he can
duplicate George,
not George Lucas,
George Lewis,
Wazniak Wazniak with George Lucas.
I lump them all together.
Roger's Kenny Rogers.
Anyway,
Steve Wasniak,
who's one of the super geniuses who
founded apple,
he has a Prius and he said that there's
an issue with the accelerator and the
Incan replicated.
He could do like a specific number of
things.
You know,
you hit the blinker,
do this,
do that,
it.
It'll happen.
And he said he could do it safely and
shows them how to do it because there's
a software issue.
That's what's so scary about these
fucking computer controlled cars,
man.
Computers Crash.
You know there's some beauty in like an
old mustang,
you know,
you turn the fucking key,
the ignition fires up,
the fucking tack is there speedometers.
And you smell the fucking gasoline.
You know what I'm saying?
There's no.
Nothing happened.
You out stupid.
You've got drum brakes.
Okay.
Those bricks suck Dick.
They're terrible.
They don't slowing down there like they
barely work,
you know,
you got,
350,
375 fucking American horsepower high
torque va,
a nasty sounded exhausting.
You just drive a stick shift four on the
floor.
Everything that got more advanced,
the more advanced it gets,
the more your ticket chances.
You've got to fucking software that
ships break on my breaks to go so bad
when I was in high school and I'm ready
to fix on.
It would be at a venture firm.
Thirty miles an hour.
That all please,
please.
They're just eventually right in front
of the car,
in front of you.
Stopped like,
Oh God,
this is amazing.
When you were allowed to drive,
when you're young,
how fucking dumb you and still drive up.
Drive me.
I should be 30 a destroyer machine that
could kill people and you're 16.
You're allowed to fucking hammer around
it.
It's so crazy.
Yeah.
It's amazing that we're all alive.
God,
I got a ton of accidents.
No car.
I drove it a retard.
These cars could not do what I wanted
them to do.
It was hitting trees.
Chip,
I mean when I was 16 I was just too way
too wild to get a driver's license.
There's no way that should have.
I should,
should've been riding the bus,
getting my shit together for at least
another two years.
By the time I was 18 I had mellowed out,
gotten used to the fact that I was
driving around and then I was knew I was
safe when she was 16 and 18.
There's no way.
Yeah.
Drive as fast as you possibly can for
the 30 yards.
Yeah.
Retard.
Just no reason.
Cutting people off
one reds.
It's scary shit man.
It's scary shit.
All the different automated things that
are going on today.
So many different things are automated.
You know what scares the shit out of me
is these drones they use overseas,
you know when they have these drones
that fly above Pakistan and launch
missiles down because we're not at war,
we're not in Pakistan,
but there's like,
you know,
talent wants to get an instead or in
Pakistan,
so we want to fuck them up.
So we send these robots in space.
I mean this is like fucking.
This is really like science fiction.
We send these flying robots that we
remotely controlled from a base
somewhere.
These dudes are literally using xbox
controllers because these kids are so
used to playing xbox.
They know those computers so well.
They just program the software to
control the drones to use that same
device.
So we gotta fucking xbox controller and
they're controlling what is the
controller goes out.
Well,
anything can happen.
Anything can happen.
Somebody's house.
Well,
people have died.
A bunch of people that have died.
A lot of civilian casualties lot.
Yeah,
just these drones.
I mean,
they're very effective,
but shit,
man,
you're launching missiles from the sky.
You know who the fuck knows you're
American?
No,
no.
He's already understand people getting
jack loves and right.
I mean it impacts them as well.
It's a,
it's scary thing.
Now they fired something called Hellfire
missiles.
Imagine that.
That's what they named them.
Hell fire know.
Not like freedom maker or something like
that.
You know,
with a bad afterlife.
Yeah.
Not like,
yeah,
I like the strong arm of peace coming
from below and you motherfucker hell
fire.
That doesn't make you feel good.
The whole idea of the whole war.
So crazy.
What's really crazy is that the CIA had
the president of Afghanistan,
his brother on his fucking payroll.
Really?
Yeah,
and this guy is like deepen the poppy
business.
The CIA was paying him.
It was just recently revealed that the
CIA has been paying him for a long time.
He was on the CIA payroll.
He's the brother of the president in
Afghanistan and he's in the poppy
business.
I mean,
the whole thing is crazy.
That's 90 something percent of the
world's heroin from,
from Afghanistan.
Guaran fucking tee,
some evil motherfucker and some high
lofty position,
you know,
I want to name the organization because
who the fuck knows is really bringing it
in even if it isn't even has a name,
but those guys are profiting off that.
Distributors for sure.
It's been proven many,
many times.
You know,
there's a plane that the CIA had,
and we talked about this before on the
show with this plane,
had crashed in Mexico with four tons of
cocaine in it,
and it was a jet that had been to
Guantanamo Bay twice.
It was a CIA.
Jack is fucking jet,
had been to one time obey on two
separate occasions.
And this fucking thing was flying
cocaine into the United States and
crashed in Mexico for tons of coke,
man.
Hmm.
So many different stories about if you
want to,
if you want to look any of this stuff
online,
look up that,
that playing the crash.
Then look up the story of Barry Seal's.
Barry Seal's was a guy who was a,
uh,
a drug runner who would fly drugs in
from South America to the United States
and drop them off in Mena,
Arkansas in a little plane and he would
drop a parachute.
Will these two kids saw the dropoff one
day?
And they caught the kids because they
didn't want the kids telling they killed
them.
And their parents found out that it was
a murder because the cops had said that
they found these kids on the train
tracks apparently,
that they placed their bodies,
but travels went over and they said,
oh,
they got stoned and they laid out on the
train tracks and the parents did.
Autopsies hadn't had an autopsy found.
They found knife wounds.
The kids had been stabbed.
So they stabbed these kids and killed
them.
And then they laid him on the tracks.
And so then it became this gigantic
investigation who was flying,
blah,
blah.
They get ahold of this guy,
Barry Seals and bearings.
Seals is totally spills the beans,
tells the whole story.
All the different shit that he did,
he's ready to testify,
goes to court and they fucking
assassinate him.
Literally,
I was waiting.
So this dude's eyes weighted court.
He's got George Bush,
George Bush,
his phone number in his pocket at the
time and he gets murdered in his car on
the way to talk about it.
And this was the guy that was an
employee of the CIA.
And there's,
there's not just those,
because a bunch of them,
Michael Rupert is a guy who wrote a book
about it.
He was an lapd detective and something
in Lapd.
I don't want to,
I don't know what he was,
but he busted the CIA selling drugs and
he's like,
and he was told to the back off the case
and he's like,
this is fucking insane.
And he's written books about it.
He's got this website from the
wilderness.com,
I believe it is.
You know,
it's all,
all detailing,
all the different corruption that.
And they're doing it right in front
everybody's fucking face.
That's the crazy thing.
I mean,
think about how much God damn cocaine is
in this country.
It's not all coming in because of
retarded criminals.
Because most people that are struggling,
a huge organizations and the compliments
the government has to do with it for
sure.
Someone and some some aspect.
Why wouldn't they?
If these are,
if these people want to do drugs,
you know,
what the fuck?
Let's who's making money off the drugs.
They probably feel like,
look,
the bad guy's going to make money off of
drugs anyway.
Let's just cut them out.
We'll take the money.
Fucking drugs are going to be out there
no matter what you do,
and it's all like a nice little cycle
because the more people get arrested for
those drugs to more of the prison
private prison companies and companies
that own these gigantic prisons,
the more they're happy because more
people are in the prisons and the more
people that are in private prisons,
the more profit they make.
So they support are the shit.
So they actually support drugs being
illegal.
They want them to be illegal.
They pushed for it.
It's fucking crazy.
The whole,
the whole big package is fucking crazy.
And the idea that the government is
behind it all,
if there's evidence of it just makes the
whole thing mindblowing.
It's just so nuts.
The fact that the BDA,
you know,
is like in cahoots with the CIA and they
all.
It's all like a big game at the very
top.
It's all horseshit.
So I'll just profit and money.
How much fucking money save in Macon?
Oh,
he must be so much money in drugs.
Who gets the money?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
Right?
How many people are involved and where
does it go?
I mean,
if the CIA,
if someone in the CIA,
someone in the organization really is
selling drugs.
Is it just every now and then or a rogue
agent goes fucking nutty and cut some
deal with some fucking killer.
Do you think it's all the time?
If that's how it gets in the country?
Well,
if.
Yeah,
I mean,
how many times has it happened?
how much cocaine did we have already
here?
How long does cocaine last?
You know,
if you bring in a whole gigantic ship
full of it,
where would you keep it?
How long does it take to get it on the
street?
Someone's bringing it in.
It's not these morons.
It's not.
They'd be getting busted left and right.
People that are so crazy,
they're willing to do something that
insane.
Like some Mongo,
a million dollars for the cocaine in the
country because people are crazy.
Those people get busted doing shit.
That's not an option that part of like
they hire somebody to transport.
The more people you hire,
the more people are going to kill you.
the the worst year idea is because the
more people that can get busted and wear
a wire and put you in jail,
it's very dangerous.
The smart move to do.
If you're doing something to hire as few
people as possible,
take your own ship over somewhere.
It might be a way to do it.
Might be the way to do it.
You might have to bring your own ship.
No Way.
Some cartel guy transport to know.
Those guys don't do it.
They hire other guys,
do it.
That's why they was living these fucking
gigantic compounds with 15 dogs and had
guns and no fucking nuts,
man.
Imagine that life in Mexico,
they've gone crazy.
The Mexican drug war is just off the
fucking chain.
When we talked to victor about it,
you know the dude,
he just got out our guide from the UFC
who does a Spanish commentary.
He does my job.
He just got out of Juarez.
He was living in Juarez.
That's what he says every time it's a
knockout.
Yeah.
Does he?
Oh,
alright.
So I should have let that go.
That was my biggest regret is that
you're not telling everyone.
Now you know,
Victor says this.
That's the lyric.
Because I thought he did.
That was just saying because Michael k
one commentary and he goes really big
commercial.
The guy gets cracked.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
He's hilarious.
Convention.
He says crazy shit
all times
that says,
oh yeah,
yeah.
They let them just do whatever they want
it.
The people love it.
I think he's hilarious.
He's my favorite guy to listen to him.
He's a man.
We hung out with them and I know that
somewhere in Canada and Edmonton.
Then we hung out with him and his
girlfriend again in Australia.
Super Cool.
Dude.
Couldn't be nicer.
So he's Australian.
More hooks than a pirate connection.
That's my favorite one.
Pirated.
My name is mom borrowed.
How can we not hear about the fucking
Somalian pirates anymore?
They got canceled.
We've got bored of escape.
There's two people ever escaped that
girl.
English couples still fucked.
Oh really?
Yeah,
they still got those bitches ain't
locked up and kidnapped him.
They want millions.
They know these guys are worth millions.
Who knows what they're doing to them
until they're probably fucking them.
They've been there.
Were surprisingly good about once you
pay the money to get everything that's
said,
but what do they do now?
These people aren't coughing up the
money.
I bet they're fucking them.
They might.
Why not?
Why wouldn't they fuck them?
These pretty white people.
Silky smooth.
White skin worth billions.
These cats are like super,
super rich.
Want her there?
Or do they just like regular folks who
did the people that were kidnapped on
the yacht,
like the guy and the girl and they were
like real travelers.
That's so scary.
I was attending about it.
We are in 2010 and this is the Internet.
So we're gonna find out because I think
that's fucking interesting because
that's one of the things about traveling
is that um,
the,
it gets fucking nerve wracking thinking
about what is safe and what is not.
And all these losses of countries don't
have overload.
Yeah.
When I was in Brazil,
that scared the shit out of me from us
to Brazil was A.
Brazil was very much like a Sao Paulo.
It was,
um,
there was a feeling in the air like,
yeah,
you gotTa Watch where you go.
Most of the people were very nice,
very friendly,
a lot of beautiful houses,
a lot of Nice neighborhoods,
but it was also like they are.
I'm sure if you go to the market and
it's been Jerusalem,
you're welcome to the airport.
People are don't.
While someone from the navy witnessed
it,
snapped British yachtsman oh,
he's a yachtsman.
Wow.
Is this passing ship?
Do you want what?
Oh my God.
She's pasty white.
Now she's just,
she's pacing white.
Their pasty,
white,
rich English people.
Oh my God.
They must have fucked shit.
Nothing.
Fucking people.
And these guys are nuts.
They went from Turkey through Africa,
down through Saudi Arabia to some Samira
love.
So far off the twitter.
I'll put the link up.
Pirates versus Ninjas.
Who would you choose?
The parents this longer than.
Where's the ocean or last names is
always the immediate answer for why.
How are they going to take the ocean?
They don't want both and then just says
why it's better because when you're an
injury,
you know for sure you can kicked up a
house.
Yeah,
no one's a.
You make a movie where it's like a
Ninja.
He's tired.
Your fucking 12 it probably 12 year old
boy son.
Like he takes off his mask and he has
like a little eyepatch under his mask
and there's like a squished like,
okay,
these people have not paid yet.
The pirates believe these people are
wealthy.
That's what it is and not well things
they put in their yacht.
All their money they put into the yacht.
Wow,
these guys are fucked.
Wow.
This is scary shit man.
They went nutty man.
These people sailed all the way down to
fucking Somalia.
What the Suez Canal went to move by.
They want to cross the ocean to India
and then they went all the way back
towards Tanzania and that's where they
got jacked.
There's some dream of sailing around the
world,
retiring the center of the world.
Parents did that,
you know,
my parents went to the Florida keys and
then up in the Bahamas for awhile,
you know,
but it's nerve wracking,
man.
You're living in a fucking boat out in
the water and you know when the storms
come,
you're fucking houses literally flopping
back and forth and it,
Michael under other houses are going to
crash into it.
My Dad had to get up in the middle of
the night and go out to in the middle of
horrible rough waters,
climb on other people's boats and secure
their anchors because they didn't secure
their anchor correctly and their boats
were drifting and they had to worry
about their boats slamming into it as
really.
Yeah,
it's dangerous shit.
And they had a little bit of a little
sailboat.
They lived on a little sailboat for a
couple of years putting daddy shit,
man.
What up?
Anyway,
what I'm trying to say is you go to
other places,
you realize like,
God damn,
we're lucky it's safe here.
You know,
because I take flights,
human beings are.
We are only as civilized as our
circumstances,
you know,
and I learned that when we were in San
Francisco and the fucking,
we thought the building was on fire,
you know,
I,
I was really thinking like,
how am I going to do this?
Well,
when we're evacuating it was 15 flights
of stairs and people were going down the
stairs in single file and people were
panicking and they were asking
questions.
They were stopping the line and they
were going really slow and they were
shitting their pants and while this is
all happening,
you could look down through the spirals
and see the smoke coming up from the
bottom and I was ready to jump.
I was ready to just start climbing down.
I was ready to just start,
fuck you.
I'm just going to start climbing you.
People are panicking and they're not
going fast enough.
They're there.
They're like freaking out and everyone's
and every floor they're merging.
You start thinking like,
this is how someone could die.
You can die like this.
You can get stuck in a fucking fire.
Man.
This is scary shit.
Very,
very scary shit.
Yeah,
that,
that really freaked me out and I now I
hate going to,
I used to like to be at the top floor
for some reason I guess high as I can
get,
like when I go to a hotel second floor
we get because of that,
you know that that was one of the worst
times in my life.
That's the only time ever I thought I
would for sure was going to die
don,
but I thought we were in a very,
very bad situation here.
I was very thankful when we got out and
everything was okay and it turned out it
wasn't really a fire under the smoke was
actually the fire extinguishers because
he's assholes.
Got Drunk and like 4:30
in the morning just started spring.
You know who's saying that it was him
that's bringing this show.
It probably was so dare you who?
But it was a whole fucking room.
The whole floor was covered in this
smoke and the fire alarms went off,
I guess because they activated the a
thing,
so it was no real fire,
but God damn was scary as fuck and could
have very easily been a fire.
It's terrifying.
Shit.
Good energy can just overcome,
you know,
because one of those old ass buildings,
they're not safe man.
Single fire staircases.
Oh,
that was awful.
They could suck it.
12 floors going into one.
I was on the floor is going into one
staircase and I think it was other ones,
but they were like hidden staircase.
There was so many people that were
walking so slowly we're panicking.
Oh.
They had just woken up and they were
delirious and they were unhealthy and
they weren't athletic.
They weren't like people who can move
well,
so he'll get up and some people need a
long ass fucking time to get going.
Like they're in their sixties and
seventies and all of a sudden you put
them on a staircase is like,
oh my God,
I'm going to die because this guy can't
walk.
If you got to walk faster,
buddy,
you gotta walk.
There's,
there's a gap in front of you,
motherfucker,
you know when you normally there's a gap
on the stairs,
it doesn't mean shit,
but when you see smoke on the second
floor and there's like,
you know,
10 feet between you and then the next
guy like,
dude,
you gotta move man,
what are you doing in my cap?
Attacking Brian,
playing with it.
You put a sleeve over as a or she
scratched it up.
Can't play.
You can't rub her belly.
She likes to fight.
We'll be right back.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Now we're going to go to your emails and
calls and calls.
Eventually.
What are we going to do?
A skype thing.
Zoom,
skype.
No,
don't do it right now.
Fucking Johnny Depp.
Live.
Pirate.
We are already likes the pirates.
That's why I bring a collection of
sheets just in case I need to tie them
together and dip.
I don't think I wasn't thinking about
it.
And the lower I got the more I was
thinking,
okay,
maybe I can jump out from here and live.
They've got to jump around from here.
And then you start thinking crazy shit.
You know,
your,
your survival instincts,
you really become an animal.
You become an organism that's trying to
survive.
You know,
you don't really think about anything
else.
That's why this end of the road shit's
crazy when the zombies come and shit,
because I'm going to be like the first
one that I eat,
the heart.
You know that somebody in our group.
Why do you think that I have.
No,
I'm just kidding.
But I think zombies.
We've talked about this before.
I think this whole idea of reincarnating
people after they're dead,
you know,
like the whole cryogenics thing where
they're taking people into freezing.
I'm like they did with Walt Disney.
I think if there are really zombies,
that's a Zombie.
The Zombie is when a person dies,
their soul goes the next stage of
existence,
their energy,
their essence can you just read,
make their flesh and the flesh needs to
stay alive,
but it doesn't think at all.
It's just moving on.
Instead of trying to keep things in
front of it and try and bite your army
it because it's hungry.
Remember that old experiment with the
dog where they brought dogs back to
life.
You ever see that?
Just the Russian film.
What is that?
Oh,
you got to look that up on Google there.
They have like this head of a dog and
they hook it up to these chemicals and
the dog just starts coming back to life.
Starts Licking his lips.
What was it?
Russian Russian scientists.
Scientists.
Dog Dead,
but giant Black Madonna.
Lack resilience.
I rushed in sciences.
Dead Dogs.
Severed head alive.
Did.
That is one of the creepiest videos I
ever saw and that's probably something
like that.
Zombie dog right there.
That's,
that's a Zombie dog that kept alive with
electrical stimulation.
I'm imagining like if they made it a
thing that they could just put a collar
on its neck to do the same thing like a
executive or write things,
I can control it.
Well,
I think for sure.
You know,
one of the things that those people.
Here's the video.
Wow,
that's the dog.
Oh my God.
Zombie.
Is there a video?
I'm going to put it on twitter first so
we can all watch together.
Jimmy Kimmel,
you either watch him,
you know it was the best name.
That thing that he did with with him
when he came up as and this whole show
is to do that.
Things work and you tweet it.
That's a cartoon.
That's real.
He's just explaining it,
explaining how he definitely was feeding
the dog.
This is just a mad scientist shit.
They're trying to figure out what makes
flesh and tissue alive and this dog,
they're feeding blood.
This dog's head while this fucking dogs
head is severed.
I mean this is.
They're explaining it in a cartoon form,
but then watched the do it is
freaky.
That's insane.
We kept.
That dog's a alive for hours.
It's moving around.
It's reacting.
When he tickles his nose.
Can't park has been a voicebox.
It's got an old lungs man or he's got
nothing.
It's,
it's saying citric acid.
He's taking citric acid and when you get
to put her eyes,
nose,
can you imagine doing that to like your
old pet because you want to make alive.
I'm looking at that is insane.
The dog's head is completely removed
from his body and it's licking its
knows.
The guy covered its nose with citric
acid.
So like here,
it's a cute dog is looking at those why
they have to chop his fucking head off.
So did they.
Just to figure out that you can do it.
It's blinking.
Oh my God.
They put light on it.
Oh dog sound.
Sound that I picked up a hammer.
Smash his face.
Know the ground with a hammer.
You watch a video.
Always reacting to that.
He's trying to get away from the hammer
noise.
Oh my God.
It's so crazy.
Now,
did they cut his head off and put it
right on that machine already?
Chopped his fucking head off.
They didn't bring it back to life.
Don't kill them.
Don't know exactly how long it was,
but this crazy guy did a bunch of these
kinds of experiments.
Fuck,
that's so scary.
It's like,
are you guys willing to do something
that that dark.
I mean,
I understand it's all for the name of
science and all that stuff,
but the guy who's willing to take an
animal and completely disregarded
suffering just to find out what you can
do to it,
that guy will do that to people.
That's what I think.
I mean,
maybe not elaborate.
It's where's the line?
What is the line when you want to take.
There was a guy who,
uh,
who recently got arrested.
I want to be in charge of choosing been
sent,
being sentenced right now.
He was on a dating game back in the
seventies and this chick turned them
down and I'll find that to the,
turned him down.
And after the CIC turned him down
because of the chip,
didn't want to go out with him.
Well,
it turned out he,
before he was even on the show in 1968,
he had already raped a child.
He raped a 12 year old girl and they
didn't know about it.
So he gets on the show.
He went and the girl doesn't want to
date them.
The girl doesn't want to date him,
so he goes on a fucking killing spree.
Killer.
No he doesn't,
but he kills a child.
He kills a,
I think for people.
Took one teenage girl out into the
woods,
sodomized her and smashed her fucking
head with a rock.
I mean,
he did some horrible,
horrible shit.
He's moving people.
Fuck.
And um,
I mean,
that guy.
Let's do cut his fucking head off.
You know what I'm saying?
You guys killed four people.
Raves and sodomized and check hills with
the rock.
Let's cut his head off.
Why are we kidding?
This dog didn't do shit.
You know,
that guy is the one passion number one
will fucking kill you.
That's what it is.
This is the guy.
This is him in court right now.
We gotta wait older.
Well,
this is 1978,
but he went on a fucking killing spree.
He raped her with a claw hammer so he
repeatedly,
all of them will repeatedly strangled
and then resuscitated during their desk
to prolong their agony.
So come up again.
He's just an evil evil.
Fuck yeah,
she was hot and smart.
She smartened up you may 19,
78.
She knew that the other dudes who were
on the show with him,
he said that he was so creepy.
They were like,
I didn't even realize it,
but they were leaning away from him and
they said they didn't elect the locker
room like it was the dresser in the
green room.
It wasn't like all jokes like,
hey,
we're on this crazy TV shows like I'm
going to win you fucking piece of shit.
It's fucking show.
Like he was like aggressive with them
and like crazy.
Like this guy's fucking creepy.
It turns out he's a serial killer.
You know that guy.
We should experiment on that
motherfucker.
Right?
And that's the guy who should be
telling.
Not it got dumped on,
but entrepreneur,
I want to sit with them asking me
questions.
I know,
right?
He's the defense to Oh,
even better.
And I wonder how they caught him.
I don't know the whole story.
I don't know how to go look at him.
And what a creepy fuck.
There's people that enjoy,
they truly enjoy hurting other people.
You know,
they're,
they're broken.
Their wires are just completely crossed
and they actually enjoy it.
Man,
that's fucked up.
But talking about medicine and how we
tried it for the monkeys,
did he really big garden that would have
still gotten crazy,
would have been a crazy monkey way more
crazy because what if he became one of
the monkeys and he got fucking famous
and they had incredible power.
I mean the power he had over checks.
He was three feet tall and fucking ex
con and it was all over.
You always have hot checks around them
so everyone in Hollywood and putting
them over and don't think dudes don't do
plants get suppose because there's
always guys that are like in Vegas,
especially that party.
They'll say we get a lot of hot chicks
with us going down there.
They were always trying to talk to like
UFC guys and fighters.
Like why you?
Why are you telling guys you have a lot
of hot chicks with you?
If you have a lot of hot chicks with
you,
like are you like just a really super
cool guy and wants to make everybody
happy or they're just trying to make
friends with everybody and this is like
the bait you're throwing out there to.
Yeah,
it,
it was weird.
That's all right.
That's Manson Shit.
The problem is always going to have a
lot of hot chicks and you're like,
what am I going to do with that scary
shit?
Meet them.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well the prostitutes that are willing to
have sex with me or something.
The other ones,
like what do you understand?
Do you want to talk about your,
uh,
your last talks to anything I went on
last comic standing against it.
What do you mean been talking about?
You mean by rules of like NBC?
I have no idea.
I'm sure you're allowed.
And then I get there and they said this
year they want to do,
um,
what's it called?
A more respectable uh,
judges because they're afraid of aunt,
uh,
that level of comic where they were
like,
oh,
people don't really want to do it.
So they got Greg Giraldo and Andy
kindler arrives back and then at the
last minute I found out before I got
there,
I went on that my ex girlfriend Natasha,
what are the experts,
but now this is not just an ex
girlfriend,
but there's a,
there's a big ass story to it.
And one of them is that at one point in
time was quite upset with her already.
Uh,
yes.
And uh.
Oh,
the water.
Yeah.
Yeah,
she uh,
she left me for some guy and mad tv and
then um,
and then she started hanging around a
lot my safety spot,
my clubhouse and making it uncomfortable
for me.
And then,
uh,
she started dating my friend and then
she was hanging around the club house
again.
I threw water on her face,
so not the best judge you'd be online,
not the one I want to be up.
And then they started grilling me about
it,
like right before I go on and Cameron
asked me this question before and I'm
like,
dancing,
what?
Absolutely thought about it,
but I'd love to cuddle situation so
much.
I even said that.
I was like,
Oh,
you do,
if I could be better,
but I think we all do from working at
the store,
it's just so awkward.
I love it so much that I'm willing to
put myself through it.
Just to the awkwardness.
Well,
you know how when we were doing store
all those years,
we'd have those crazy late night shows.
Like I think there's something about
those late night shows that like,
you know,
like there's times when we did gigs
together where like if I did a Gig with
Tripoli or me and Bret Ernst and um,
and um,
Mike Young did a show once in Hollywood,
Florida and everybody killed.
And one of the things with Brent and
said when he killed,
like right after he was bringing me up
comedy store,
a motherfucker,
you know,
and it was like joking around like a
clubhouse.
It's a mentality.
It's like,
you know,
you're working hard situations.
The comedy store,
if you don't know the way it has always
been in La,
used to be that the criminals ran the,
the insane people run the asylum.
But now it's more,
it's managed.
It's kind of sucks now because still the
door guys all want to be comments.
Everyone's a content.
They're outside smoking and drinking
when there's five hecklers and they're
yelling at you and eventually someone
will get them.
The places entirely black.
Everything's black.
The walls are black,
the floor is dirty,
the coloring is black.
The building a whole building is black.
It's black building and it's just dark
and it used to be a nightclub where
Bugsy Siegel owned in the 19 thirties
and ship called Ciro's and it was like a
mob joint.
We're like,
dudes were killed there,
you know,
so it's got this weird fucking feel too.
I mean for sure.
They chop people up and throw him in a
fucking freezer in that place.
The,
what's it called?
The window where they said that Louis
used to watch the opening acts from
their greenroom agreement has a window
you can and we can still use it today.
You go out there and you watch the main
room,
but they said that because of where they
point out for the bouncers,
let's get him out so they wouldn't have
to go and make a hubbub in the room and
just drag them out.
They said the reasons,
but it's just.
It was.
It's an amazing club.
There's three comedy rooms in it.
There's an upstairs,
little tiny one called the belly room.
There's a an original room that's like
200 seats right about twitter and then
there's a main room.
It's like 400 seats and fucking club is
just so sick.
Man.
So much fun shit has happened in that
club.
It's a great development room.
That's it.
It's the best place to write material.
It's.
It's less about like,
I don't know.
People are so impressed with you there.
Don't showcase their.
Never.
You'll eat it.
It's very possible that you could never
tell you,
but the key to make a table that don't
make a tape of the store,
you can never tell what's going to
happen.
You never tell.
We've been showing situations where
people are screaming things at each
other,
fights on stage,
always pulled his cock out at least 10
times that I know of.
If I would be willing to bet money that
he's pulled his dick out 10 times on
that stage that I saw because you saw,
yeah,
to suppose balls at all time and just do
a set of balls out Stephen.
So I put my balls who hated anything
homosexual,
so I pulled my balls out and left a long
tee shirt over them because we're going
to bring them on and I had them out
before the entire set and there were a
couple times where I raised my hand like
this and people would say just go up a
little bit.
So I had to be conscious of doing my set
my hands down whole time and then when
he got out because we were doing this
thing called cocking or would come
behind you and just put my ball when
you're at their arm bank,
just somewhere on your body.
We never did the girls because that's
creepy.
That's illegal.
It's illegal to do is do dues too.
But if you call the cops,
you're a bitch.
He was like,
don't you ever do that to me?
I'm like,
I'm going to copy you.
And so,
uh,
so I went to shake his hand and have to
get off and I just pulled it in,
melted
for 15 minutes with regular jobs.
Can Not appreciate that there's
something very fun and being juvenile
and you know,
everybody wants to get all mature and
everybody wants to know that's all well
and good.
Bottom line is your,
this is a temporary life.
You're,
it's just temporary.
Taking yourself or anything seriously
seems dumb to me.
It seems like you should be having as
much fun as possible.
Even as silly,
stupid shit on each other.
I don't care.
It could be a hundred years from now
forwarding on.
People are still going to be funny when
Joey Diaz comes over and then waves his
hand in front of his ass.
I mean,
it's always funny.
It's always disgusting,
but gets warmer clothes.
The only time that would make you angry,
you'd have to be so fucked up in your
life,
like you have to be in a terrible.
But if at any normal time in life when
it does that,
it's hilarious.
The date.
Can we do this?
What are you doing?
Hey.
Hello.
Mrs.
Very nice to meet you.
I'm getting it.
Smoke it.
Sorry about that one.
Yo Dog.
You got to give it right back.
Would definitely do the.
He's stolen more letters from me.
I should've learned some fucking home
and beacons.
Put a put a little beep.
Beep,
beep,
beep.
He used to always talk about him going
to a 7:11
shit.
Still Steel
steel steel at the airport.
It's like 30 minutes.
We're going to miss it.
Like don't.
Does he still do it?
He just,
he does the tic tacs.
Remember when we went to Mcdonald's and
it was one of the places where you
grabbed like a quarter pounder.
You drag your fries and you go to the
cashier.
A quarter pounder fry.
He's just like quarter pounder.
French fries in my shirt.
Get rid of the time I stole that food.
You just gave him up.
Huh?
You just gave them up on the Internet
talking about Dunkin stressor.
Brian and I were.
Were waiting for once and I forgot to
wait in line and then somebody kept
yelling out ketosis,
ketosis and nobody picked them up.
Switch the fuck it.
Oh,
that's right.
I forgot.
You guys are killing me,
man.
It was scary.
It was scary and so fast.
I mean,
I got caught for shoplifting was when
CD's first came out and I was like 12 or
13 or something and I wanted a CD so
bad.
I had a CD player for my birthday.
They had one CD.
It was a ghost buster to soundtrack.
So I was like,
I need a new CD.
The soundtrack sucks.
And so I went to the store with my
friend and we,
uh,
I stole three cds and got caught and it
was so embarrassing as the CDs were
Paula Abdul Mc Hammer and something
else,
like van Halen or something like that.
But then his family are.
Both of our families had to come.
We had to.
Oh,
getting caught shoplifting never got
caught.
I got caught shoplifting,
shoplifting,
shoplifting when I was about 13 or stole
a candy bar and uh,
we were about to leave and go to the
movies and as I'm walking out of his
store,
this guy came up and grabbed my arm,
really fucking went to a panty.
Goes,
what'd you put in your pocket?
Go what?
What is this?
Why get a candy bar in your pocket?
Like,
I totally didn't even need to do it.
I just want to see if I could do it.
I've done it a couple of times.
I'd stolen like gum or something like
that and I just kept doing it.
You know,
when you're a kid you do,
you can just do it.
I didn't think I was 13.
I was like 12.
I think the thing is you would have
gotten in trouble with your parents.
I was 13 because I was living in Boston.
Yeah.
My,
that's terrible.
Yeah.
My parents can find out about it.
I don't think.
I don't think they even told my parents
just told me get the fuck out of there.
It was like a candy bar.
They didn't give a shit.
But like,
we could hold you,
we can bring you to jail.
And I just said,
look,
I just want to scan.
I don't know why I did it.
I'm stupid.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
And I said,
uh,
I,
I got away.
I told the truth.
I said I got away with it before and for
whatever reason I thought I could get
away with it and like get the fuck out
of here because Kevin,
our fucking country doing this,
I'm going to put you in fucking jail.
Big Mustache,
big fucking fat head and got my face.
And I was like,
yes sir.
Yes sir.
Thank you very much.
Yeah,
I'm glad I got caught because if I
didn't I'd probably since I was so
addicted to it because when Nintendo
came out also surface service,
service,
merchandise didn't know about video
games.
We just put them on the shelf.
So me and my friend were like,
Ooh,
Ooh.
They put 10 in our pants and then we
would bury it outside of the store and
get it back later because we didn't want
to come home and have like video games
in
high school.
Got busted stealing like a thousand
dollars where the shit she got some real
trouble.
Wow.
Girls are.
And I saw these pair of sunglasses that
I thought were cool.
I put in my pocket and as I'm walking
out the door I'm like,
what am I get?
This thing goes off right now.
What am I doing?
And I was like 17.
It was like enough where I'm like,
they'll just charge me.
I'm not cute.
Yeah,
it's um,
it's scary shit.
My girlfriend at the time,
I think she was 15 when she got caught,
but she just wanted nice clothes.
Everybody had nice clothes and she was
also a raised without a dad.
I think when people are raised under
dad,
very unbalanced,
you know,
more subjects do crazy shit.
Her mom worked all day,
you know,
her mom didn't have enough money to take
care of her.
She couldn't put her in like a really
nice daycare.
So you grow up,
you know,
single parents or single single parents,
single child,
you grow up a little crazy,
you know,
she just thought she could get away with
it.
She thought she was smart.
She was pretty smart.
Start to get away with it either because
she was raised with no data are raised
with too much dad.
Yeah,
she wasn't.
She wasn't.
She wasn't fucked up like that.
She was just a little crazy.
You look back on on chicks that you knew
when you're in high school and say,
well,
if I got her pregnant too.
I had a fucking kid with her.
What if I was still connected to her,
but if I was pregnant and didn't have
money to the real answer is,
well,
can you imagine though?
I mean not having money is one thing
that that does suck,
but being young and not having money and
trying to figure out how to raise a
child,
you chose still trying to figure out
yourself in the best of your life,
the rest of your life,
but it's so hard not to project on those
people,
but it's like,
no,
it's fine.
I would hate to fuck it up.
I was going to fuck up.
You know to,
to raise a kid when you're a kid
yourself,
man.
That's.
You could do some irreparable damage to
that fucking kid.
You could teach them something,
some really terrible behavior patterns.
They even model them after you and me,
think about how dumb you were when you
were 18.
Now imagine you are black.
He had aids and you're.
Yeah,
you live in another country.
How about you?
Just by practice.
That's what the new presses.
Yeah.
I haven't seen it,
but I couldn't imagine.
How about you born in the Congo.
How about that?
How about you?
One of those dudes that fucking still
fishes by hanging a net over fucking
moving river from a tree.
They hang with their feet from fucking
trees.
Scoop to the water to.
It's not because the river is raging and
if they're not even wearing safety vests
and if they fall in that water,
they might be fucked.
There's some video.
These guys live in the Congo that are
catching fish by doing that.
It is wild to see man,
they are living right now.
The the fucking Navi lived in Avatar
because no bullshit except they don't
fly back.
Cool.
All the uncool or they come at you and
they're killing things with spears and
bows and arrows and you know,
their fishing with nets while they're
hanging from trees.
It's local.
It's crazy shit man.
And these guys are living in 2010.
They don't have shit.
They don't have lights,
they don't have electricity,
they don't have anything.
They have no lighters,
they don't have shit.
Occasionally you see one of them will be
wearing like,
like western underwear,
like somebody got them some fucking
underwear or there won't be wearing a
tee shirt or some shit like from the
gap.
And you're like wow,
this is crazy.
And here they are living in these straw
huts in the middle of the fucking jungle
surrounded by monsters.
You know,
that is a scary,
scary life man.
That could have easily been us.
You know,
you didn't have.
People want to where you were born to be
born where I'm born.
You could totally fuck up and all of a
sudden you know any different.
But goddamn.
How lucky are we?
I mean,
yeah,
you would be probably okay.
I mean,
people.
There's a lot of.
I think they look down on our lifestyle
and look at them.
They don't even know if it could have
been born here in Afghanistan.
I had a good luck,
critical that they're proud to live in a
shitty towns.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that are proud
to live in Pittsburgh.
You know what I'm saying?
For Real.
You know,
you talk to people they fucking love
Pittsburgh.
Pull a dog.
Fucking.
Pittsburgh's the only time for me.
Or do you need to go to Australia?
Because let me tell you something,
man.
Everyone's friendly.
The women are gorgeous.
Everyone's cool as fuck.
Everyone's super,
super relaxed.
Every third place to organ goes to
visit.
This is the greatest place every month.
The moon with that want.
I always have this instinct to get out
of La.
La Land came so close.
I was gone dress when I thought it was a
track me back in.
They've fucking got me back.
The wife got knocked up in the mountain,
lion ate the dog and snow came accident
on the hills.
It's just too much.
I got crazy.
I tried to move her right to the
mountains.
That's,
that was the big fuck.
I should've moved to boulder and got
like a little take over territory then
move.
I got this very strong desire to have
like a base very far away from the
majority of civilization.
Like I have these crazy and it's not
crazy thoughts of like the end of the
world.
It's just like I just want no one around
you even do that here.
It's like any reason you have to be in
La is 45 minutes away.
We'll hear well in light traffic.
Yeah.
Have you always been like that or is
that something that had knitted
recently?
No,
I've always been like that when I.
I've moved further and further away from
the hives in the moment I moved to La.
When I first moved to La,
I had an apartment in north Hollywood.
Then I bought that.
I rented a house in Encino and then I
kept going further and further out,
you know,
and my next movement.
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna stay in California and say I'm
going to get a place in big bear.
I want to go and get a place up in the
mountains.
You know?
Yeah,
maybe I should buy his place,
but it's like I wonder if she'll sell
it.
I want to lend.
Even uses it.
You don't like that.
What the fuck?
Junky spirits in that fucking house.
Okay.
What are you trying to do?
We're worshiping Satan.
Joe Rogan.
He's in India as you know what I would
like to get just a little cabin,
just somewhat somewhere where I can just
go and just hear nothing.
That's what I love the most.
Medical.
I mean,
you,
you went to that place when you are out
that window when we were on the porch
and you listen,
you don't hear a fucking thing.
It's,
it's,
you hear the silence.
It's like a very specific sound of its
own.
I've heard in the redwoods
as [inaudible] the canopy so,
so high above the ground.
There's no real birds and there's no
real insects there.
Um,
because the stuff,
I don't know how it falls up so there's
nothing going on.
So we really is just silence
occasionally here.
Squirrel whenever you see one.
But generally it's just like nothing's
happening.
I got to go back to that suck.
No Man is supposed to be was like miles
and miles around and we drove our car
through the tree and I want to,
I want to do that.
Douchey people are fucking trees had
been around for like a million years is
gigantic fucking treat.
It's as big as this room or what do they
do?
Have a big hole in the center of it so
people can drive their cars through the
fucking tree.
This is like a novelty goof.
Like they carved out.
Well,
that's where the road was,
right?
That,
that's where the road was.
They didn't have to do that.
I mean,
it seems like more humane to kill the
tree than to use it.
It's a fucking cherry.
Trees can feel.
They just can't communicate,
you know?
And that's a very valid argument,
you know,
we don't know.
We know that there's,
um,
I don't know if this has been
scientifically validated,
but there's been all sorts of studies
that prove that,
that tree's like,
like feel something like there's an
electrical impulse when you snip them.
I will tell you this,
there was an episode of Mamma's family,
uh,
in which the goofball son,
here's a study that says a cauliflower
can feel pain.
Broccoli does not have that same
problem.
Maybe that was where all the work was
done.
That's not real,
but who the fuck knows,
man?
You know,
who knows if it doesn't hurt their
feelings when you eat them,
who knows?
It's not a good enough reason to,
to or not to do anything argued that
video game characters can probably feel.
Maybe they're playing a pretty quick,
maybe you're fucking somebody up and
another dementia that,
that video game.
How do you know that has feelings?
As much as I'm a cabbage,
you know,
that's just where it starts getting
ridiculous.
Then who cares?
You know,
you have to have lips.
They won't eat anything that has a face.
Yeah.
There's,
there's like people who will eat,
they will eat things like they'll eat
like clams and they'll eat like some
shellfish and what?
They won't eat anything with a face.
What does that thing?
Speaking of faces creeping and mass
cheap,
but it's got someone's mouth.
They're not watching some girls,
so for Brian just comes up with weird.
Have you seen us in a weird ass banners?
We're talking about the thing that's on
my website.
It's on Joe Rogan dot.
No,
well,
there's weird bands and saw Brian.
I'd like to throw in a lot of subliminal
porn into it because it.
It works.
Yeah.
I think that you're like,
what the fuck is this?
When it makes you look at the poster,
he lives down there by the end.
Yeah.
It makes you look at the poster where
like a lot of times if it's just you
with a microphone is like,
okay,
yeah,
whatever.
You just know.
I love them man.
But I think if you just brighten the
contrast in there will be even more
excited with the n is I feel like I see
something.
Right.
Isn't it funny that that's exciting to
almost see some tips or some policy,
but you can see just
you can just go to a different website.
Internet.
Yeah.
I can't live in a mountain man because
if there's like any of the road shit
happens,
I need to be around just in case I might
have to meet.
It's not even an end of the world and
you have to discuss it,
but it was like,
it was like overload.
It's just too much to too many days in a
row where it was like,
oh,
that's why they're doing this.
Sometimes I overloaded on the road,
on the road.
Sometimes too much porn.
I just see it as maybe being animals.
Either that or this way where I just
feel empathy for women.
How about when you beat off and like
only a dribble comes out because that's
all you got left like a three,
three day or four feet off like three
times in a day.
And you think you're doing it because
you'll try and get some sleep like you
in the morning.
Like sometimes I wake up and I'd get up
too early and I'm like,
I can sleep in.
I need my sleep.
Let me just turn it off real quick.
So jerk off and then I'm like,
get ready to go to the gym.
I it a little horny for the gym.
It was just jerked off,
jerked off,
and then I'll go and do the show and
then I go to the show to stand up,
go to the for Jujitsu.
Sometimes
I want you to three times
wash for Jujitsu,
very conscientious,
listen to everybody jerks off and then
it goes to Jujitsu.
Everybody that goes to Jitsu jerks off
and then goes there.
It's just a matter of.
How long ago was.
That wasn't a month ago.
Was it a year ago?
They like to wipe it or they go away.
That's true.
You never know.
And can trust people.
Trust no one.
But then I'll go get home from the Gig.
I'll do a Gig,
I'll be wired and then I can of get some
sleep so I'll beat off man,
get some sleep.
What?
At the time I didn't know where it just.
Oh,
I kind of already about this.
He's a sprayer.
Like when he,
when he chokes out,
it just blows up once in a while and
it's based on the shoulder.
Why does it do that?
Or do you like hold down the tip like a
garden hose and try to spread something
like that?
Probably the way I do it,
I don't know,
just got a lot of fucking time.
Just because you come with.
No,
not me.
Oh,
so it's a girl doing it or me I'm doing
it for whatever.
It's like,
let me just let him beat off.
Or if she does it,
just fuck it.
Let's be honest about something.
What is better?
A great load,
a great low,
shooting a great load or taking a great
shit.
I would go to the great,
great mode,
but not by much.
Not by much.
Give me that.
Here's a great look or grid much for the
question.
Here's the question is how many times
have you shot a and then you realize,
oh my God,
now I have to talk this crazy bitch that
I just shot a load with and she's trying
to get the fuck out of there and you're
tired and you realize you've got to
drive an hour to get her to stay over
and you're like,
I can't.
I have to feed the dogs.
Like any kind of craziness that goes on,
you're like,
oh my God,
what am I doing with my life?
Whereas when you take a shit,
there's none of that.
I think here's the load in your show
point.
Just had sex a lot more than Brian and I
are more like interested in like,
yeah,
whatever.
But we're like,
what sucks
drug?
Good Shit.
I really appreciate the morning ones.
Sometimes you wake up and you're like,
oh,
Jesus says,
well you get the toilet.
So it's like,
because I eat a lot of salads,
you know,
machine comes quick,
so it's like
blah blah blah.
See My,
my Shit's always involved in
investigating and identifying,
looking at your poop.
Well,
that's because Brian has blood in his
poop.
No
once in a while.
It's right now.
I'm just making that up.
I'm ending up now.
I,
uh,
once I had a hemorrhoid and it had to
get A.
I already talked to internal
hemorrhoids.
Yeah.
Right.
So that's why he goes to investigate.
I could upload it puts.
It's just like,
Whoa,
what is interesting about it?
Find out what I will go to wipe like,
oh,
was that a winter?
She said,
I was like,
oh no,
it's super wet.
I could never tell a story about.
I just like,
it doesn't hurt though.
They were telling you about when I,
uh,
when I first started wearing a cup and
Jujitsu I didn't use,
I had to start wearing makeup because I
was rolling with Einstein and he was
trying to pass my card and he slammed
into me right into my Dick.
Like,
not even like my shin hit my balls,
but they need hit the Dick was,
the president had it a lot more.
Why?
Why are you covering your head?
Because I hate this story.
Oh sorry.
But he's slammed it in my.
To get hurt so much it was so fucking
painful,
but so I wait until I feel better,
you know,
I take a couple minutes to catch my
breath and then we started rolling
again.
I didn't think anything of it until I
get changed.
I go in the locker room and I go to take
my.
I take my pants off and I go to take my
underwear or my jock strap off and it's
filled with blood filled with blood.
Blood is leaking out of the tip of my
Dick.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
I broke my Dick.
So then I go into the bathroom and pee.
So I go to p and blood is just coming
right out of tip my Dick Blood in urine.
So then I started thinking about it.
I go,
okay,
I got a problem.
I've got to do something.
Now I've got,
I've got a problem.
I might have to get my teeth fixed.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
And then I thought about it.
I'm like,
okay,
but wait a minute.
If this was my nose and blood was coming
out of my nose when I do anything about
it,
no,
I wouldn't do shit about it.
I would just let it heal.
Okay,
let's just,
let's just let your Dick Hill and see
how it goes.
So I'd get home that night and I say,
well,
I don't know man.
Maybe I should go to the fucking doctor.
Okay.
If my dick get hard,
I'm not going to go to the doctor.
So I jerked off.
I jerked off and I shot a bloody load.
Is it pink?
It will know.
It was like a chicken egg that has the
embryo in it.
You know what I'm talking about?
You get a chicken egg and that's in the
Philippines.
That's a blue balloon is like an actual
embryo,
like a big ass.
Much more close to kosher.
You get one drop of blood in the what
you get all the time and then throw it
up and use it separately.
No,
it makes sense.
You don't know what the fuck happened.
That things bleeding there and that
blood is human life has we killed
differently than a human lives.
But not only that,
it's probably smart for like health
reasons,
that blood is just sitting in that egg.
An egg can keep probably better than
blood.
Ken The border,
I mean that's just speculation,
but your bottom line is I jerked off to
see if my dick was okay and I know it.
It didn't feel that good,
like the best jerk off session I've ever
had.
But then the next day I peed blood a
couple more times.
People are just a little bit less every
time for like three days.
And then I stopped.
There was no more blood and I said,
I think it's okay.
I think it would have only taken one day
and I would have freaked out and went
right to.
It didn't hurt.
That's why.
No,
no.
God.
Well I was thinking I was.
What I was worried about was that it was
going to break.
You know,
I was like,
my Dick is not going work anymore.
I'm my.
I'm infinite off.
You imagine if you get gang green.
If it were to rebuild one,
they have to take a chunk out of meat
out of your forearm.
I saw that online,
a dude had his dick rebuilt and maybe it
was like a woman who had a dick rebuilt
to become a man.
It could be a fake Dick.
Oh,
that's so crazy.
Wouldn't you be concerned at all at the
time?
And I'm not joking that the doctor would
be like,
if you hadn't gotten hard so fast would
be okay with the fact that it broke the
seal or something.
You weren't worried about that?
I was thinking that maybe my loads with
purified whatever injury I had in there,
my soldiers for the work on it,
patch it up.
I thought you were going to do that.
I think urine is supposed to heal
things.
So if you pee when you have a little
wound inside your dick is probably good
to piss out blood and cleans it out.
Yeah,
you're in sterile.
It's good for you.
I bet.
I bet it probably does,
but I,
that was a close call.
So from then on I wear a coat,
so no,
uh,
no blood in my shit but some bloody
loads.
It's bloody pep.
So yeah,
it was beautiful.
Beautiful.
What you sort of lead,
what I don't do shit that involves
having a wear cups of people won't hit
my nuts.
I don't people.
I'd never worn one Jujitsu.
You should wear one dude.
I'll get an extra one too.
He likes to swear.
Sounds fishy smelling Ben Gay.
Tried it on and do with fucking Dave's
insanity sauce and it won't even kick in
until you start sweating and you
imagine,
Oh my God,
your Dick would be on fire.
I pissed was after I had a,
a Burrito with days and Saturday sauce
and I just,
I don't know,
I'm not saying that some residue on my
finger.
And I touched the head of my deck and it
was like,
it was melting like a Mexican below
John.
It was,
it's like that for all of the sunflower
seed peppers,
sunflowers in Israel.
They have this huge sunflower seeds like
that big.
And so people always take it from my
desk.
So I wanted to punish the people who
didn't ask.
Oh,
so you put.
So I spent all day and I crushed up.
How about Arrow peppers seeds out and
put one seed inside each sunflower seed
and then if people.
I'll leave that in front so people ask
that,
but no,
no.
Here's the normal ones,
but if they wouldn't,
they just fucking get it.
Most people can't stand the heat but do
not wash out my hands period and just
had to shower with my pants around my
ankles and it just start like,
oh,
oh.
And you're like,
what's happening?
Water Pepo do to get their dick
tattooed.
Yeah.
What the fuck man.
How much most sensitive area hasn't
built a tolerance.
Anything.
Jesus Christ and it feels awesome.
Can you dictate?
Maybe it's just like hard.
Brian wants to get fucked.
That's what I wonder if anybody's
tattooed to Dick and had them come on
them.
Put the pause on the balls.
You just scored so low.
Yeah,
they definitely have gotten hard before
to attend to it.
That's definitely happened and she's not
even on purpose.
Not even appropriate.
It could just be incidental.
Especially like really crazy freaky gate
bond type.
Do you know,
has bravo bid on that Tattoo show yet?
Eric?
An,
I don't know,
I mean I think they filmed the whole
season in advance and he just did it a
couple of months ago.
I was a good ass tattoo man.
A chicken.
She's a really good artist.
Eddie Bravo got his grandmother tattooed
on his chest.
Incredible.
Incredible artwork.
Man.
I fucking love those tattoos.
I don't have any of them,
which I love those portraits.
Yeah,
it'd be creepy unless it means something
to you.
Like for Eddie,
his grandmother was the person who
really cared about him when he was a
kid.
You went to high school with the kid and
then all of a sudden you run into him
and he's got you tattooed on his arm and
be like,
listen man.
It's ironic.
We just picked her out of the yearbook
at random.
Don't be weird about it.
Usually that crazy ambitious.
I'm going to kill you.
Ray Romano tattooed on her back because
she hated her mom.
No,
she just did it because you know
everybody loves.
Raymond was not tattooed as a tramp
stamp.
It says I'm going to kill you,
Ray Romano and how she's thinking it's
out.
People are interested.
It's on the Internet.
Yeah.
How crazy is that bitch is that bitch
ever has kids and the kids can never
take her seriously.
Like,
mom,
listen to me.
You've done ask.
You've got.
I'm going to kill you.
Ray Romano on your fucking back.
Those Ray Romano.
That was a popular sitcoms decisions,
which might have been your best
impression.
Brian.
He's hilarious.
That guy.
I started working with him like way,
way back in the early nineties.
We did Jimmy's comedy alley in I'm
thinking was in queens somewhere in New
York,
I think it was in Queens.
And uh,
he,
he was the headliner.
I was the middle.
I got to see him like when he was at his
peak.
He was a really,
really good standup man.
Twitter's good.
So yeah,
it's interesting.
Well,
he's always good.
He's just,
he's,
he's just got a great delivery,
you know,
he's just a,
he's a super nice guy.
He's always been kind of clean,
you know,
clean.
Like he did a bit on Kevin and been show
last year,
so April foolishness.
Hilarious bit about if guys could blow
ourselves,
we'd have to wear like a dog collar.
It was really fun.
Get more into it now.
So you couldn't.
So you keep your,
your husband from blowing himself.
He would have to put out like one of the
girls was a very funny man.
It was a really good bond or something.
No,
no,
no.
It was very funny and he had a bunch of
good stuff.
You know,
just even stuff like about Sun pooping,
you know,
you think it's like it's innocent
trumpet.
It's really well worded and great timing
and really good economy of words.
He's a really good craftsman know
material.
That's why I show is so fine.
That guy,
I met him,
you know,
here's a new job I did.
I didn't steal somebody else.
Luckily somebody else called.
I stole it from that pilot.
Yes.
He got it.
And then they fight.
They didn't want him for the actual show
and then they hired me.
That's what happened.
So I didn't,
I didn't feel bad.
There was already bad before me.
I just took it from him.
But Ray was a friend,
you know.
So it was weird to run into him,
you know,
but then all of a sudden he got his
show,
which was like 100 times more successful
in radio and was perfect because he
controlled the whole thing.
And when,
uh,
when we were hanging out,
when you first got the show was me and
him and Kevin,
Kevin James,
we're all eating dinner at Jerry's Deli
and ray was like obsessive harm.
Maybe if I have the guy come in like
this and just kept going.
He was like obsessed with the.
Yeah,
just putting it together perfectly,
you know,
he was really like trying to construct
it in his head and he was obsessed with
it.
It wasn't.
There was any good luck at all with him.
He had to take this hbo special back
when it really meant something and they
were holding it for like a year,
year and a half where they're like,
no,
we're not ready to release it because we
want to do this.
He's like,
I'm broke.
I need some money,
please.
People will see it.
Right.
Wow.
I suppose that's always a concern when
you have a special and you film it,
you don't own it,
and this is before the Internet,
you know,
you could really get crazy and go,
I'm going to fucking releases on the
Internet.
You guys can suck my dick if you're
really crazy,
you know,
if they caught you though,
you'd be fucked.
They caught you and they could prove
that you took away the profits for your
own thing.
Like they pulled my shit from youtube,
my own shit.
Yeah.
They've had the.
Yeah,
that's nuts.
When your own bits get pulled off your
own youtube page and give you the
copyright.
So they said don't say hbo with other
searches for that.
Ah,
that's very smart of broader.
Yeah.
Do you put that up online?
You're HPL sets.
Are they going to do more of those?
The downed dirties?
No,
no more.
they didn't like it.
I didn't think got ratings or something.
They're not promoted right away.
Not really.
Hbo Does Not really handle comedy that
will promote a pin,
which I decided to draw,
but too often it seems like they're just
trying to put things that are like
different.
Try to.
It's not like their new one is all sober
comedy.
That's a new series of like with Boston
Norton.
Oh really?
All sober people there.
The good thing about that is a lot of
the guys that are sober,
sober for a reason,
so they've got some great stories.
You know what a church sobriety this is
like,
I fucked up my life.
Sobriety.
There's a lot of dudes like that.
There was a lot of dudes that were doing
a clean,
clean Christians,
a comedy tour.
They were like bank loans.
Oh my God.
And they would call the corporate.
Went to arenas like big church arenas in
the south,
like giant fucking places and just
terrible,
terrible happening.
He came in and said,
ma'am,
that's not my hat.
Seriously though,
just really like,
you know,
there's,
there's a big push for that with a lot
of people.
Like they want the lowest standard
possible.
You're gonna submit,
you're going to,
you're going to broadcast the lowest
possible standard and there's so many
people that want to hear that,
whether it's in country music or at
Sarah Pailin,
talking or it's you know,
they want,
they want no,
no difference between you and them.
You are just as smart as them.
You don't talk down.
In fact,
you talk them up and make them out to be
much more than they really are and
that's like a big,
if you're religious,
but for the grace of God or whatever,
they're getting through it,
click cool.
I've been so crazy and so spooky that
we've gotten.
Our culture has made things so easy for
idiots to survive.
It's soap mean most of what Pr.
There's so many people that do so many
different things that are so useless and
they're going to be replaced by robots.
I'm a substance that Florida is what
they watch,
the comedy concert.
He goes,
that was a worst Christian rock concert
I've ever seen because it's ticket.
Simon says Chris Rock and he goes,
somebody f words.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
The Christian Russia.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
I just think it's so easy to be a retard
these days because there's so many other
people that you join with.
Did you ever see the video?
There's a comic who interviewed these
people waiting to see Sarah Pailin at a
book signing.
There was like a whole fucking giant
line of people and it's like three
degrees outside there,
freezing their asses off and they're
waiting for hours to come in and meet
Sarah Pailin and so the student goes and
interviews them and asks them questions.
What would you like about ms dot Ms Dot
Palin policies?
It's all the same nonsense.
Nobody has a clue,
but in all fairness,
I've seen the same thing with Obama.
You know,
when they interviewed people that there
is no,
he's black and he's talking to really
good and he's good.
He went to the thing with,
I think it was bob
or stuttering John Thompson.
I might've turned out,
but they went with someone else
completely,
but they went downtown and asks about,
um,
what do you think about Obama?
What do you think was running mates
therapy when people are gone?
I think she's great.
I think it was great.
Who Do you,
are you a Democrat
or Republican?
The Republican,
and they're like,
what about,
you know,
like that forever.
I watched that Gonzo,
that Thompson back in the 19 seventies
when he was running fewer loading on the
campaign trail was the same thing.
They were asking all these different
people and who you're voting for it.
No one had a fucking clue why anybody.
No,
not that guy.
And I was like,
who the fuck are you voting for?
And that guy's vote counts.
Just as much scholar.
Yeah.
They like Obama.
So you know he wants to go to war with
Iraq war.
How do we feel about that as well for
it?
What do you.
Do you think that there Obama has any
say or do you think it's all horseshit?
What do you think literally happens when
you.
When do you think that you've been
briefed before the editor when I said
this is what's going to happen,
you're going to be given an agenda.
You're going to be asked to follow
certain protocol.
You'll you will consult with these
people before any decision before any
press conference.
It will be reviewed.
Some of that,
but I think they're also just met with
with checks and balances.
It's way harder to get things done when
you think you don't have to make
allegiances and you have to give certain
things in order to get.
Definitely,
you know,
definitely.
There's definitely a lot of that.
There's definitely a lot.
We'll just get something done.
It's not that easy.
No,
no it's not but.
But okay,
but what's with him saying that he
wanted.
It was all bullshit that you don't want
to have troops over there and then all
of a sudden he pulls them out of our ach
and sends him off to Afghanistan.
What does that all.
Because I think she realized like,
Oh,
I can't just pull them out so it creates
a vacuum of power that will be terrible
and what I wanted to do.
Now I know more than what it does.
You know what?
I think what they've gotta do at some
point in time,
they've got to have some map.
If they really want to get people to
like the United States and other
countries,
there has to be some massive goodwill
operation where we go to these
impoverished countries,
these places that had been wrecked by
war,
by devastation,
by all these different things that are
going on and we have to help the fuck
out of them because if we don't do that,
then other people are going to look at
us and go,
what?
What is,
why would we look up to the United
States just because it used to be just
because it's the biggest super power
because they have the most missiles,
you know,
why would we give a fuck about them?
And if the people at the very top aren't
the most generous than the whole,
the whole system below you seems unfair
and people get fucking pissed off.
Something that Old Testament or a light
unto the nations,
you know,
lead by example of what you want them to
do.
Sure.
If you're in that position,
if you're in the position to be
generous,
if you're in the position to help,
if you're in the present,
it's just we're just ganking shit.
That's the problem.
We want the oil.
Fuck you.
Give us that natural socket and we're
going to go,
where's those poppy seeds?
Where's the heroin ground?
Right here.
Shut the fuck up and sit down.
We're bringing in guns and tanks and
fucking jets and we're going to have
space ships that fly around you by
remote control and shoot missiles into
canyons.
Dude,
you ever watch those videos online?
They have videos of them launching
missiles from like helicopters and shit.
If these people that are walking with
donkeys,
I mean it's fucking nuts,
man.
Walk in.
You seem like walking up the hill.
I went,
got to target.
Should we engage when you see it like
his arms?
Who knows whenever the fuck knows what
they're doing.
I mean,
you know,
it could have been.
Somebody just said the wrong thing to
some fucking general.
Who knows?
I don't know what they did.
I mean I'm just watching a video.
It could be that there are some high
level operatives and are moving through
their secret cave hideouts and who the
fuck the house John Heffrons watching
Prophet John Ron.
That was the.
I also the comedy club at skyline comedy
in class.
What are you saying?
Skyline comedy club is watching and they
were like,
come to Appleton,
Wisconsin.
Where is John Heffernan playing next?
I've only been to Wisconsin once and
went to some crazy summer festival.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
It was an outside of the 10th.
Thousands of people.
Awesome.
Outside.
Yeah,
it was really great crowd and.
But it was like a lot of people with
babies and shit and I'm saying,
oh,
it's nasty shit.
I'm like,
I'm sorry.
It was on.
Bother me nearly as much like yeah,
there was kids too,
man.
There was everybody and I was.
I did all my shit because there was a
lot of young people in the front,
like a majority was like hundreds and
hundreds of young people and then behind
them there was like a mixed bag,
but the people that were sitting,
we're all like,
you know,
your average comedy club audience.
There was just a bunch of people outside
and the people are standing up and
walking around and it's in a big giant
tent.
It was so strange,
but I'll do it once because I was too
dirty.
They will not have any back.
John Heffrons in Atlanta.
Where's the punchline?
Punchline.
Prophet John Safran.
Very,
very funny guy.
Funny.
Every time I say him,
we'll see him.
John heffrons ready to come to Arizona.
Well,
I think John will tell you that he would
love to come to Arizona if the improv
comes with the shackles.
You know what I'm saying?
You gotta come with the shackles from my
man.
John headphone.
So what do you think about a little
wayne?
Wayne went to jail.
Well,
it's about time.
Do you think so?
Just another one already.
Little rapids.
He has crazy tattooed up.
Have you seen how much he's whole body's
done?
Yeah.
We've got to put that online for people
who haven't seen it because it's fucking
bizarre.
Like it's so crazy.
Like it's hard to believe that this dude
has this many tattoos.
I mean,
like this whole body's fucking tattoo.
Oh,
ready to wrap it?
Shut the fuck up.
We will give a little wayne tattoos.
Need some coffee song.
I got so much.
Six to.
What do you ever do have to get a
macy's?
Okay,
sounds hard.
What are you going to do that right
away?
I would never trade lives with you right
off the bat.
That just sounds so horrible.
There was no way.
I wish that upon my worst enemy.
I've got amazing.
Amazing.
It's hard to find a new one.
Oh,
here's a good one.
Here's a good one.
God Damn.
This students got a lot of tensors.
Look at this shit.
Oh my God.
That's incredible.
Cast money.
Yeah.
This is incredible.
He's in a position where it really just
doesn't matter because it's not going to
get a job.
Yeah.
Well,
he doesn't have to be right
ever,
man.
That's nuts.
I'll put this up on to it.
That's crazy,
man.
He just went off and tattooed his whole
body.
That's like a big good all at once.
No,
I don't know,
man.
Soldier boy seems to have that.
Soulja boy do.
Do the same thing.
Tattooed his face.
Tattooed his hands,
tattooed his chest.
His whole arms is.
I mean,
he just went nutty.
If you're googling soldier boy,
you can't find it.
You're spelling it wrong.
Yeah.
It's like a soldier.
Slu l j a hollow and also Google a
soldier boy.
Ice Cream.
Kitty ice cream.
Kidding?
Yeah.
Powerful show.
Fear.
So for you got to unblock me for me.
Twitter.
Don't be rude.
I can't even follow you on that road.
It goes both fucking bug me too much.
We can read it right now.
We could still read it.
Just have to go support.
I promise I won't bug you anymore,
but it still lets you just go to your
will.
You know,
go to the website.
Yeah.
Up a stream.
No,
not on Dennis tweet deck,
but we can always go to your page to see
what you're up to.
No,
come on man,
but you can't fuck with me.
When I was about wanting to commit
suicide,
I won't fuck with you about anything
anymore.
You don't really want to commit suicide.
We just want to be happier.
Right.
Would you rather if you have the two
options,
right?
Well that's like,
so you don't really want to throw the
question on passage.
Went away however I get there.
It's not like that.
It's like that.
It's not like that at all,
Lou.
That's nice and gamble.
That's what little wayne has to say
about it.
This whole lot bodies like a fortune
cookie.
He's got little unfortunate to be
sayings all over his body.
Wow.
That's so weird.
That's like really fucking really bad
tattoos,
man.
It's weird.
That's a see a real trend that guys are
getting these really bad.
It's like prison tattoos.
But the crazy thing is,
you know,
it comes from self,
a gangster,
all this crazy shit,
but he goes to jail and the first thing
you did was go into protective custody.
Oh.
Because they're afraid of.
How did you do that?
You just apply.
Um,
that's a good question man.
I had a head of time,
like when you get the camera and say,
my client is a very wealthy man who,
you know,
a lot of people could get a name off,
beating him up.
He's not a very big man and he's
concerned for her safety.
My favorite things is when it is like us
to walk through the law and what we
would say to the judge in order to get
things done.
We're only going off old law.
There were sort of guessing old
episodes.
I think what you have to do is tell the
judge,
your honor,
I don't even know what to monitor when
TV shows have you that you could tell it
like if a cop was like undercover cops,
you'd say,
are you a cop?
And they have to tell you the truth.
I'm a cop.
She taught me that off this time lefty,
but next time you already,
you know you guys are never going to
trick me like what?
They would never do that.
They don't have to tell you they're
cops.
That's ridiculous.
You're doing something illegal.
A cop can let you do that illegal shit.
They can do illegal shit with you.
They can do fucking cocaine with you to
arrest you for cocaine.
How about that?
It's legal and they can get away with
it.
You know how many is that?
Because if they go under cover,
they're going to have to do drugs with
you.
If you're doing drugs and you want to be
a part of some motorcycle gang,
the motorcycle gangs,
doing drugs,
you got to.
Drugs will not be able to,
but yeah,
I'm on TV.
They'll dump it off the side or the one
special episode where they had to do it.
Yes,
exactly.
They throw their fake it on amazing
stuff.
I'll give you an antidote pill.
This will immediately notify the
cocaine.
So as soon as you take it and make your
way into the bathroom.
Almost gotten credit for job interviews.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean it's just.
You hear about that all the time with
dea agents,
the DEA agents get addicted to drugs
because they have to do with these
fucking people to get in with them and
then also I think they just see that
fucking lifestyle.
They become crazy.
They see how many people are getting
away with it.
I think if you were in the position to
really be investigating drugs in this
country,
you would see there's so much trucks
coming in.
It's like an unstopped before he would
start wondering like,
what are we putting our resources
towards?
Why isn't this shit legal?
Where they can tax it and make money off
of it.
You know,
why can't they just go after the illegal
people there?
It's just like prohibition.
When prohibition happened in the
thirties,
all that shit did,
or the twenties,
it was like what?
Like 1933 or something that all it did
was just made people that were more
dangerous sell.
It made people that weren't afraid to
break the law.
It just made organized crime strong.
They kept a lot of people's hands and
most of my stuff,
I don't know man.
I think it made people angry about
getting busted with it and selling it,
but I think most people want to get
drunk.
I kind of aren't going to break the law
rather risk it,
you know,
because a lot of people who are like,
oh,
I guess we can have it anymore.
I mean,
did you ever research or just speculate?
I'm just speculating,
but if they made cigarettes illegal,
completely illegal.
There's a lot of people will start to
wonder if it would be like Catholic
school girls and being horse because
there's a disproportion amount.
Say some.
Growing up around a lot of Catholic
school girls,
it was common knowledge amongst my
friends that Catholic school girls,
they go religious Jewish school,
not.
Well.
I think Catholicism is so ridiculous
that I think even like the,
when you're dealing with a religion
where a gigantic percentage of the men
who are in power are fucking little
kids.
The other one got caught.
I said it was good.
It's another anti gay rights.
Oh No,
no.
That was Roy Ashburn.
Yeah,
that was the guy who is.
He was the guy driving proposition
eight.
He got caught.
He admitted he was gay,
but that guy's not a priest.
He's not fucking kids.
He's just gay.
You're like,
they're all the same fucking pedophiles.
You loved this guy in with a pedophile.
Would that religion is so ridiculous
that there's.
There's a giant percentage of the men
who are pushing this religion are also
fucking horrible pedophiles that ruin
people's lives.
If you know anybody that's Catholic,
if you grew up in a Catholic community,
you know a bunch of people that have
been molested.
Everybody knows somebody.
I know two people that got hit on by
priests.
I know my friend Tony,
he had a fight off a priest and my
friend John had to fight off a priest.
They get attacked,
his priests fucking drool on them and
breathe on and pull the end.
My friend bought another dude.
I know three dudes.
I know.
Three dudes that got a.
they're all Catholic.
No girl.
That money from a settlement.
Dude,
there's so many settlements.
If you stop and look,
do you know New Mexico has some crazy
ass fucking law or they used to at one
point in time where you could if you had
sex with a girl,
like a man cannot have sex.
We grow like it's normal age.
The age of consent was like 18,
but if a man to have sex with a boy,
the age of consent was like 13.
Really?
It's fucking crazy.
And the reason why supposedly this was
inactive,
so the Catholic church put pressure on
them to keep this in place that they can
fucking ship all their sweet boy ass and
they would sneak it.
I don't know if this is true.
This is all speculation.
This is all in the Internet faculty.
The fact that speculation,
the fact is that the age of consent for
male to boy was 13.
That's fucking nuts,
man.
Same sex males is like 13.
Whereas opposite sex like boys and
girls,
what's really crazy now is the sexting
thing where kids are going to jail for
child pornography because they're taking
a picture.
They really.
They came down at some point with like a
no tolerance.
I don't care if you've made it,
but you can't have on your hard drive.
No one can have a well there.
Those laws like we can make an exception
for anyone.
They are attacking slots for,
for sending pictures of their pussy.
Two guys,
they're attacking silly.
It's basically the same thing.
I'll show you mine.
It all played that when we were kids,
but then the problem is then it gets out
to fucking pedophile for maximum go
crazy.
That's what they said.
They didn't want anyone to have it at
this twice.
So we're talking about again,
the point is send us some sweet pictures
of a 13 year old Bush.
This is important shit because it's
fascinating.
It's fascinating shit man.
The idea that you can put kids in jail
because they take pictures of their
pussy,
you know,
the dude's sends a picture of his Dick
to some girl in schools now.
Now he's locked in a cage.
You know,
that's silly.
People throughout time it's,
there's a charge in whipping your decap.
If you cover someone's Dick up,
they're gonna want to whip it out.
We all lived naked and free.
You know,
he wouldn't have to worry about this
shit.
Then people would start fucking way
earlier.
We all live naked and free.
You wouldn't be able to trust anybody
ever where someone will actually fucked
by accident would have to happen.
I'm wondering how much suppression,
you know,
we really have by walking around naked,
like how much different we would we'd be
if we walked around naked.
You know,
I'm walking around all closed up.
I wonder how much more different I
behavior that will tell you this.
This is the comparison.
Is that so any sort of nudity is like a.
It was like a novelty when I was showing
a gear.
When I went to touch women,
you know,
when I would touch them even on the arm
or something like,
oh yeah,
it was like an electric sort of feel the
other way more sexual.
So I think covering up and stopping
yourself,
it makes you more sexual so that if you
were completely unclothed you'd be way
calmer.
Makes it more urgent.
Yeah.
When I first came to La and our first
acted in a sitcom,
I didn't like being here.
I didn't like this.
The sick,
the whole say comp situation was really
bad.
A lot of negative energy that said a lot
of fighting going on in the network and
the producers and the writers and uh,
I'd broken up with my girlfriend and I
moved out here and we were still talking
about home,
but I didn't,
I didn't know anybody here.
And I was out here for a few weeks.
I didn't talk to anybody,
didn't hang out with anybody.
And then this chick,
we were laughing about something.
She gave me a hug on the set and she
gave me a hug and it was the best
feeling in the world.
It wasn't like a regular hug.
She hit me with his hobby.
I was like,
it was like I needed it.
Like she gave me a glass of water,
like,
you know,
and it was just a hug man.
She's just being nice and she gave me a
nice hug and rub my back and I was like,
wow,
that felt so good.
I just felt you need that human contact.
Yeah,
if you go like a few weeks or a month
without touching anybody,
that guy that we were talking about
earlier that lives in the Arctic,
he went,
uh,
I think eight months at one point by
himself just up there hunting.
And he said it was way too much.
He said he went crazy.
That guys just live in wild man.
You got to see it.
Some VBS TV,
I think his name is Heinemann high,
most Arctic refuge.
Just look up Arctic VBS DOT TV.
It's fucking incredible,
man.
Like one of the most incredible
documentaries ever.
You stopped to think about it like this
guy has chosen to live like that in this
day and age.
Whereas we think if we had to live like
that will be hell.
Like Brian,
how do you think you would feel if like
all of a sudden civilization dropped
off,
there was no power and you had a fucking
light fires with wood and kill animals
to stay alive and it was fucking
freezing cold out and you were an
animal.
Shit.
That's what I need.
I couldn't live on top of a mountain.
I couldn't be like that because that
shit didn't happen.
I don't want to be on top of a mountain
it all by myself.
I want to be around civilization,
around civilization.
There's no food.
No one's growing anything.
There's a lot of mooches and chaos.
Want to see some more self sustaining,
right?
Yeah.
But I mean it's.
I think it's like,
I mean my family grew up on farm,
so to me it's just like,
wow,
what if some food,
you know,
I think by,
by the time if he runs out,
we'll have tomatoes,
we'll have,
you know,
you have to have a serious work ethic to
run a farm so you can't slack off at
three weeks.
I didn't know anything about farms until
I started working for the UFC and then
you start talking to the,
a real pharmacy and I'll talk to Matt
Hughes and all these guys are,
when they do like a in depth reports,
are these guys in their life,
you know,
Tommy Spears and another one,
like they offered him a fight recently
and he couldn't take the fight because
he was in the middle of the harvest.
What else?
Like,
that's real shit.
You know,
these guys,
they're out there working hard working
man.
They're working all day,
every day and it's brutal.
It's hard work.
And there's a mentality that a lot of
these guys love the work.
There is something,
something very satisfying.
Something,
you know,
that goes back to our days when we first
discovered agriculture,
you know,
it's like a visceral Schumann,
reactional you get,
you feel rewarded for having produced
all this food as a family.
That juice shit.
There's a fable that God,
because he loves his children,
um,
gave us a plentiful cattle and crops
without us having to work for it at all.
And the man went crazy and started
working on itself was so then he took
that power away.
Then you had to actually toilet soil and
then people were waiting for calmer.
What are you doing?
Why are you in planning?
I've got to take off.
Take off too.
Don't just unplug the battery charge.
Calm Down Joe.
Um,
I don't remember what we're just talking
about.
What would you start about?
Brand farms and that's why hunting this
Guy Chemo,
I think that's his name that lived in
the Arctic.
That's why he was talking about how
satisfying it is to be a hunter and
gatherer.
You know,
that he thinks that that's where
civilization fell apart.
That man is most happy when he's out
there providing for himself.
He says he loves it.
He loves living up there.
Just hunting and fishing and getting
food that way.
It makes them happy.
It's like,
fuck it.
Go for it.
Yes.
Maybe there's something to it though.
Maybe if you did it too,
it'd be like ultra stimulating.
I mean,
I think that's one of everything.
Everybody's different situations that
other people wouldn't,
but he's doing like natural exercise
every day.
Everyday is hiking and he's shooting
Caribou and he's dragging.
He's cutting the meat and he's hanging
up,
you know,
a computer all day long.
How he's,
he says he's got a laptop but it's not
online.
You know,
it's fucking incredible,
man.
That's really what a wild way to live
your life.
Yeah.
No.
Alright,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's it,
right?
This is a long ass one.
Two and a half hours pitches.
That's how we grow.
We,
we're going to be at the Tempe Improv
this Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
Jump on it.
Saturday night is basically sold out
because it was only like 20 tickets left
this morning of the second.
The second show is 20 tickets left the
first show sold out.
And so it's gonna.
It's going to go quick.
Thank you very much everybody.
We appreciate you tuning in every week.
You can get it on itunes now.
If you go to itunes,
the Joe Rogan podcast,
uh,
is off and you can download all of the
ones that we had before.
It's all.
Thanks to that man.
Thanks for that man.
Thank you to Brian and put it all
together and he designed my new web
class.
He's the Motherfucker,
ladies and gentlemen.
Powerful,
super genius computer wizard.
And uh,
so that's it folks.
Thanks for tuning in and we'll see you
next week.
Hollow laid out.